university instructor dave gray gets
straight to the point and he will take
you from knowing nothing to
understanding advanced html concepts
hello and welcome to four hours of html
tutorials and instruction this video is
made up of 10 tutorials for learning
html that build upon each other much
like the chapters of a book
throughout the lessons in this video i
will mention links being available in
the description below i've compiled all
of these links into one github resource
that you will find in the description hi
i'm dave gray and i'm the creator of
these html tutorials you can subscribe
to my youtube channel for more tutorials
like this one you can also follow me on
twitter and if you're feeling generous
you can even buy me a cup of coffee a
quick thank you to boa free code camp
for sharing this video and to everyone
at free code camp for providing such an
outstanding resource that helps people
learn how to code for free it's truly my
honor to contribute this video let's get
started learning html with chapter one
what is html
html is an acronym that stands for
hypertext markup language
and hypertext markup language html is
the most basic building block of the web
it defines the meaning and structure of
web content and hypertext refers to
links that connect web pages to each
other and that can be within a single
website or from one website to another
overall html uses markup to annotate
text images and other content for
display in a web browser and you can see
an example of some of these markup
elements here but before we begin
creating a web page and using these
markup elements we need to get the
necessary tools so let's start with a
web browser if you don't have one or if
you're curious what i will be using in
this series i'll be using the google
chrome browser and you can download that
at google.com
chrome so if you don't have that and
want to use that go ahead and download
and install now and then come back to
the tutorial
also i will be using an extension
and we go to chrome.google.com
webstore to get extensions for the
chrome browser and there if you want to
use the extension that i'm going to use
it's called dark
new tab and you can press enter to
search for that and once you've
completed your search you'll see dark
new tab offered by keller which is the
one that i have added and you can see
added here i'll click on that
and once you're inside the page for dark
new tab you should have an install
button here since i already have it
installed
this is now a remove button for me what
this does is when you open a new tab in
the browser it uses a dark page instead
of a light page and i use dark mode
whenever possible so i prefer that if
you see me open a new tab in this
development series you'll probably see a
dark tab like this one from there we
need to get a code editor and the
industry standard right now and what i
prefer to use is visual studio code
again you can use other code editors to
write your html code but if you go to
code.visualstudio.com
you'll be able to download visual studio
code for free
and there you can download for windows
if you're on windows like i am or you
can click other platforms and it's also
available for linux and mac os so now
would be a good time to go ahead and
download visual studio code and install
your code editor and go ahead and open
that up and then come back to the video
okay i am now assuming you have
installed visual studio code and have
opened it up and you may see something
like this or you may see a welcome
screen
what you need to do is create a folder
on your computer
and we will put our files inside that
folder so if i go to the file menu and
choose open folder
you can see once this pops up
what folder i am in the html course
folder in windows and then i've created
an
0-1 underscore lesson folder so if i
highlight that and select the folder i
am now inside that folder and ready to
create my first html file
so if you see the file tree over here on
the left and it's currently empty if you
don't click this icon in the top left
which is the file explorer and that will
hide or show this file explorer we're
going to create the plus button or click
the plus button here for new file and
create a new file
now we'll type index
dot html as that is always the file name
that is expected to launch a website and
you always want to keep your file names
lower case and with no spaces now
windows will not complain if you put a
space or use upper or lower case however
when we host our files on a web server a
web server will differentiate many times
and that can cause problems so the
naming convention is to always use lower
case no spaces you can use hyphens
dashes
and then end each file in dot html
okay we have an empty index.html file
let's create our first html element and
as you might guess
the first html element we'll create is
html so if we type html all lowercase
and press tab in visual studio code it
creates the tags and by tags that is
often interchanged as a word with
element however the element consists of
the starting and ending tag and
everything in between but here we might
just be referring to the
starting also called the opening tag or
the ending also called the closing tag
so we refer to html tags but every page
starts and ends with the html opening
and closing tags and everything else on
the page goes between those tags after
creating our html element html pages
have two main areas and one area
contains data that is not seen on the
page but is considered to be metadata
about the page and that is the head area
so just type head not header but head
and press tab
and now we have our head element
and we will put metadata about the page
inside this area
but the next area is the page that every
or is the part of the page that
everybody sees in the browser and that
is held within
the body element so type body and press
tab and now we have our two major
sections of our page that are both
inside of the html element we have a
head section and a body section now
inside the head we'll just put one piece
of metadata today and it really won't
start with the word meta we'll come back
to that word in the future we're going
to create a title element
and give our page a title let's just
call this my first
web page and this will stay inside
of the html document now i just pressed
control s which saved the document you
otherwise would see a dot up here by the
index.html so i saved that and i am
using an auto formatter visual studio
code may or may not do that for you when
you save your file if you want that you
can go to the extension
icon over here and search
for a prettier extension
and i'm not sure if mine is enabled or
i'm using something else right now we'll
have to check now mine is disabled but i
do recommend this one prettier is a code
formatter that will auto format your
code but visual studio code may do some
of that as well but if you want to use
prettier go ahead and click install and
you can use that as well so i'll close
out that prettier tab go back to the
file explorer here so we see our
index.html on the left instead of the
extensions
and now we can see our html is formatted
in a very easy to read manner we have
our html element and then the head
element and then the body element and
they're separated by spaces very easy to
read and we have a title inside of the
head again the title will not be seen
inside of the browser in the body of the
page but i will show you very shortly
where we do see it
inside of the body element though let's
put an h1 element which stands for a
heading and it is the biggest heading we
could put you only put one h1 element
per page and that should be saying what
your page is about it doesn't
necessarily have to be the same text
that is in the title but here we're just
going to put hello world as is the
tradition for creating your first file
in any language you're learning and so
we have hello world on the page and we
have my first web page in the head
section let's add one more element in
the body of the page
and this is a paragraph element that
starts and ends just with the letter p
but notice each of our tags of course
start with this
less than and then end with the greater
than and then the ending tag you'll
notice has a slash but all we have to do
in visual studio code is type p and
press tab and it creates both for us so
we're going to put some text inside of
our paragraph and here we'll just put
this is
my first
web page with a period
in the sentence and save once again i'm
pressing ctrl s on the keyboard to save
you can go to the file menu and from
there you can also choose save but
you'll notice the shortcut is control
and the letter s we're almost ready to
view our web page but before we do
remember the extensions we went to i
want to show you just a few if you want
your visual studio code to look like
mine
one thing to draw your attention to is
when i created an index.html file
i have the little icon for html5 beside
it you may not have that but if we click
on extensions and then we can delete
prettier that i searched for before
type vs code dash icons
there you'll find the extension that
will add that to your vs code as well so
you can install i already have it
installed so mine says uninstall and
that will add icons as you create files
and it might add the icon up here as
well in the tab and that's how you see
the icon here beside my index.html in
the file explorer so visually it helps
you see what type of file you're working
with quickly without even reading
everything after that extension let's go
ahead and click the extensions icon
again
and then search for
github theme i am using a specific theme
which i prefer dark mode in every thing
that i do so i am using the github theme
extension and it has light and dark
themes i believe i'm using the default
dark theme this might be bright for a
second but i'll click set color theme
and yes it's switched back to light but
i choose github dark default
and then yours will look much like mine
now these previous extensions have been
optional but one that i say is a must
for you to install is called live server
so let's pull up live server by ritwik
day i'll click on that and you want to
install live server because it's going
to help us view our web pages so go
ahead and install live server and after
you have it installed we'll go ahead and
take a look at the web page we've
created okay with that installed i'm
going to close that tab i'll come back
to the file explorer here to show the
file and now if you have live server
installed you should be able to right
click and open with live server and once
we choose open with live server it opens
our browser and we can see our web page
it says hello world this is my first web
page
in addition in the tab at the top it
says
my first web page so that is where the
title goes at the very top of the
browser in the tab now this is very
bright and i have mentioned that i
prefer dark mode so let's go back to
visual studio code and i'm just going to
paste in some quick styling that is
actually css once again this is optional
but it will save my eyes and possibly
yours as we work through this tutorial
so once we're back in visual studio code
just underneath the title in the head
section i'm going to paste this in i'll
quickly describe it i put in a style
element and that allows me to put in
some quick css
and i changed the font size to make it
just a little larger and then i changed
the background color to a dark color and
i changed the font color to an off-white
color called white smoke and that's all
i did we're not really learning css here
but this will save our eyes going
forward if you want to make these
changes if you prefer the white with
dark text that is fine too but now that
i've saved this the beauty of live
server is that it automatically reloads
our page for us in the browser so let's
go back to the browser and look at our
update and now you can see our web page
is in dark mode and we have a little bit
larger text here as well it did not
change our title from the head because
that just goes into the tab of the
browser also notice the address this is
an ip address and then we have a colon
and this is a port number but this is on
your own computer this is not on mine i
can't go onto the web and see your page
that we just created we haven't loaded
it to the web it is just running on your
computer but this is the way to view web
pages as we create them which creates
your own local server it's what's called
a dev environment and that is preferred
what you don't want to do in chrome
is try to open a file like you would in
word or some other document browser or
even visual studio code how we open
files that's not how you want to view a
web page you want to use a development
server and that's what we're doing with
live server in visual studio code now if
you ever want to stop the server down
here in the bottom you can see the port
number 5500 and it says click to close
server so i can just click that it says
disposing and now we have a go live
button which you can also use you can
also right click on your document and
choose stop or open with live server now
we would once again since we stopped
that we would need to open with live
server to have a live web page that
responds to changes we make and notice
how it opened a new tab here instead of
our old tab our old tab the server for
that page closed so we close that out
and now we're using this one because
this is going to show our most recent
changes now after we've created a web
page how do we know if we have errors or
not well that's where a validation
service comes into play and this is the
w3c markup validation service w3c stands
for the world wide web consortium that
really makes the standards for the web
overall what we want to do to check our
page is click
file upload because remember our web
page is really not on the web it's just
on our computer your web page is on your
computer and mine is on my computer so
let's click file upload
and from here we're going to choose the
file on the computer
and we get a browse window and now i'm
going to click
html tutorials and then i have an html
course folder and then the zero lesson
one folder that we just created
and there is the index.html file we've
been working with so i'll click open
and now that it's here we can click
check
and we're going to get some errors and
we'll go over those
okay now that we have checked our page
we have got a warning and a couple of
errors so there are things we need to
fix
in our html file let's address these in
order with the first warning says
consider adding a lang attribute to the
html start tag to declare the language
of the document so that is something we
should do
now we're going to go to the html tag
and we can add what is called an
attribute and this is the lang attribute
and i'm going to set it equal to en
which is the abbreviation for english in
general
you can supply a dialect like this dash
us
or i believe the other would be gb
but i don't usually do that so i'm just
putting e in for english you might have
another language you prefer to put there
and you can find a list of those at the
mdn network as well and that's the page
where we were looking for the definition
of html at the beginning of this
tutorial so i will link to mdn the
mozilla developer network in the
description now that we've added the
language attribute
let's go look at the other errors we had
and see what else we need to fix
it says the character encoding was not
declared so we also need to handle that
let's go back to visual studio code
and now inside the head
there is an element called meta earlier
i said the head stores metadata let me
keep it all lower case here and here we
can set what is called the character set
attribute inside of a meta element
and from here i'll put
utf-8 which is the standard for all web
pages that i have worked on there are
other character sets but this is the
typical
value you would see in there so i'm
going to save this
and in the future we'll cover more meta
tag values that we'll have inside of the
head now let's go back and look at that
last error that we got from the
validation service
and that said start tag seen without
seeing a doctype first expected and it
shows you exactly what it wants doc type
html and that is a document type
declaration that should be on the very
first line of your page so let's go back
to our html file
go to the very top
and we'll press return
and we'll paste in exactly what they had
there so you see
once again it starts with the less than
and the greater than symbol but this is
not really an html element or tag this
is just a doctype
declaration that you should have in
every html file at the very beginning so
now i'll put that in and save as well
let's look at
the validator first and let's choose the
file again
and now i've selected the index.html to
upload with our changes and we'll click
check
document checking completed no errors or
warnings so our document is just fine
let's go to the tab with our page
and let's reload the page
and once we reloaded everything looked
great so we've got hello world this is
my first web page and we still have my
first web page in the tab at the top for
the title and we have passed all
validation checks
let's move on to what else might go
inside of our head element and remember
everything inside of the head element is
not seen on the web page and with that
said i've dragged the visual studio code
window to a little smaller size on the
left
and chrome to a little smaller size on
the right
but i'm just going to expand visual
studio code for now because anything we
change inside of the head element will
not be seen on the web page anyway so
i'll click the expand button and we'll
just see our code now i had mentioned
that we could store more metadata inside
of the head element and that is
definitely some of what we see so let's
add a couple of typical
meta tags that have metadata that you
would commonly see the first being for
the author of the page so we'll say name
the attribute name is equal to author
because that's what type of meta tag
this will be
and then we'll have a content attribute
and this is where you can put your name
i'll put my name for now since i'm the
author of the page
and then let's add another meta tag
and let's give it a name as well
and here we'll put a description this
will describe the webpage in a little
bit more detail than possibly the title
would so here we can put more of a
sentence and once again we need the
content attribute to do that let's say
this page
contains all the things
i am learning
how
if i could spell how to and it looks
like i'm extending the page so in visual
studio code i'm going to press alt z in
windows to make sure
the text continues to wrap
and then i'll say all the things i am or
i am learning how to
create as i
learn
html there we go now after that of
course you still need to close the meta
tag
and ctrl s to save and again i got the
words to wrap let's go to the view menu
if you scroll all the way down you can
see word wrap is alt z it may be
something different if you're on mac or
linux so you might want to check the
view menu under word wrap if you want
your words to wrap and not just extend
forever to the right here now we've
added more description about our page
now this information could be picked up
in a search engine or some other service
that wants to learn more about our web
page however let's go ahead and put
something in the head where we will
notice the change when we go back to the
browser and that is to add what is
called a fav icon and we can do that
with a link element let me use lowercase
once again and inside of the link
element we'll have several attributes
one is the rel which stands for relate
or relation how does this relate
to the web page and here we're going to
provide an icon
after that we need an href this refers
back to html that stands for hypertext
this is a hypertext reference so we're
referencing a resource
and here we're going to reference a file
that i have now put inside of our folder
that is called html5
dot png and if i click the file explorer
over here
you can see i've now added an image file
that's a dot png file
html5.png and you can download this
image from the resources and you can see
it's a small little icon for the html5
logo
so i'll close that i'm going to click
the file browser to have that disappear
again so we see this now we have one
more attribute to add and that is the
type
what type of resource is this and here
we'll say image slash x
dash icon and now we can save this and
i'm going to go ahead and
minimize the code window and now if we
look at our web page in the browser
notice we have an icon up here my first
web page now has our little fave icon
beside the title and that's what we
added here in the head by adding the fav
icon with a link element now we won't
add any more here today but this is the
same area where we would link to css
files and even javascript files and
other resources that we pull in from the
web so the head is a very important part
of the page even though we don't see the
content of the head inside the body of
the page and i said we wouldn't link to
anything else here today but since we do
have this default css to make our page a
dark mode if you added this and once
again this is optional if you prefer the
white page with dark text you didn't
need to add this and we had this style
element here to hold the css in the head
but that's not usually where you would
find it for a page so let's go ahead and
do that i'll expand visual studio code
again
click the file explorer
and over here inside the file tree i
want to create a new file i'm going to
call this main dot css and i have an
empty css file all we need to do now is
go back to the index
select the css that we put here for the
html on the body not the style tags just
select the css that's between the style
tags i'm going to press ctrl x to cut it
out of the page
go to the css file and control v
to paste it into the css file
ctrl s to save that file
now back in the html i'm going to remove
the style element
i'm going to add another link
and here for the rel not ref but rel
we have a style sheet because we're
adding a css style sheet
our href will now point to our css
main.css specifically
and our type
which isn't actually required anymore
but
since we have it let's go ahead and add
text slash css
but our browser should know what it is
even if we didn't add that at this point
because that's really the only type of
style sheet there is is a css now that
we've made these changes let's save the
file
and let's go ahead and click the button
again to make our code shrink back down
and look at our page we can reload just
to make sure it has reloaded and
everything looks the same that's because
we are pulling in our code i'm going to
go ahead and hide the file tree here we
are pulling in our css code using our
link tag inside of the head element now
finally i'm going to create an error on
purpose by deleting the greater than
symbol at the end of this link tag and
saving the file with ctrl s now why
would i create an error on purpose
because we want to validate our file
again and this will let us know that yes
we've got the right file and we expect
one error there
you don't of course have to create an
error on purpose but that's what i'm
doing to make sure i'm selecting the
correct file out of the correct lesson
folder because i'm in lesson two now you
might be working on the same file we
started with there's the css file and
the image file
i'll select the index.html
and check and i should have at least one
if not more errors because of that yes
that created several errors on the page
just by leaving out that one closing
greater than symbol for the link tag so
now if i save again
visual studio code formats our code
correctly instead of trying to pull the
closing
head tag up here
and i'm going to go ahead and reload
or re-upload
the file to check it so we choose
index.html
now i'll click check
and document checking completed no
errors or warnings to show so just by
missing one little thing in our page we
could have a whole list of errors so
follow the prompts from visual studio
code notice how if i leave that out here
in my theme this turns red or pink it
doesn't look quite right visual studio
code wants to format it differently if i
save the file and it pulls that up here
instead of putting the closing tag
there's several cues to show you that
you have an error in the file
and so follow those prompts in visual
studio code and then remember to always
validate your page and we always do that
at
validator.w3.org i'll get rid of
everything at the end of that and here
you can pull it up and then we choose
file upload
let's look at the basics of creating
text content on a web page
now web pages are a lot like essays or
even a newspaper where they have
headings and usually paragraphs of text
or at least a sentence or two of text
describing something afterwards so we
see our paragraph element here
and our h1 heading here
much of the text content on a web page
will be made up of headings and
paragraphs now headings have a hierarchy
and that means
we'll start out with only one h1 on the
page and each page should only have one
h1 but after that we can have subtopics
so here i'm going to press shift alt and
the down arrow again i'm using windows
it may be different for you on mac or
linux but i just copied a line down so
now i have two h1s but i'm going to
change this
by typing h2 over that h1 and notice how
the ending tag immediately changed here
in visual studio code as well so that's
helpful now this is a subtopic for the
page so imagine this being the title of
your essay or
the big headline in a newspaper and then
we have subtopics so for h2 i'm going to
type something different let's go with
i'm ready to learn
html
and now we can have a paragraph about
that and so we do at least we have a
sentence this is my first web page
now i'm going to highlight this
subheading h2 and the paragraph and once
again i'm going to press shift alt and
the down arrow and it copies both lines
down for me and i'll add an extra blank
line here and i'm going to change this
second h2
into an h3 now we i'll use lowercase
there we go
now we could have more than one h2 on
the page but i wanted to show how you
could have a subtopic
under our subtopic so we have the title
for our essay
and then we have an area of discussion
that we've added in h2 as the heading
for and now under this area of
discussion we could have further
subtopics and this is how we now have an
h3 so now instead of my first web page
or i'm ready to learn html let's change
this to
my daily schedule so this will
discuss our schedule for learning html
and then we could just say something
about i'm going to tell you how or
let me
tell
you how i and i'll just put some dots
there for now just we'll expand on that
later if we want to but really what i'm
showing is this hierarchy and it's also
important not just visually let me go
ahead and save this by pressing ctrl s
or remember you can go to the file menu
and choose save
visually we see that it's naturally
formatted larger on the page with the h1
than it is the h2 and then the h3 is
even smaller than the h2 but we can
change all of that with css in the
future css will really style how our web
page looks
but what is important is we can quickly
visually tell the headers apart right
now
and when a screen reader or other
assistive technology looks at our code
then it can navigate the code through
the headers of what is important here
the header hierarchy and that's why it's
so important to organize your page the
headers actually give semantic meaning
saying
this is the main topic this is a
sub-topic under the main topic and this
is a sub-topic under
the higher
sub-topic in the hierarchy so headers do
have semantic importance and that means
giving meaning to our content and of
course then our paragraphs can just have
whatever details we want to add about
those subtopics as well now even though
we've created a little separation in our
code when we look at our page we just
see line space line space and we don't
have a good visual separation i'm going
to add an element that doesn't really
provide any semantic meaning but
visually it helps us on the page and
that is a horizontal rule element and
it's just added like this there is no
closing tag for the horizontal rule and
then i'm going to add another one after
our final subtopic discussion here so we
can add something else underneath that
and so now let's save and look what the
horizontal rule adds to the page
now we have lines going across the page
and those are called horizontal rules so
we have our main heading and now we have
our sub-topic and i left the h3 in here
because it's a sub-topic
of this topic
so now we can go ahead and i'm going to
highlight the h2 and the h3
ctrl c to copy come down further on the
page and paste
and i'll save just so we can see what
happens now we have two different
subtopic sections and we still have our
top hello world so you could picture
this more like an essay page and of
course these could be
paragraphs that have more text or you
could picture this more like a newspaper
and then we would have an article here
and an article here in our heading at
the top this is also a good time to
discuss white space so if i just press
the space bar
and add all these extra spaces to the
page
if i say visual studio code is already
going to probably reformat this
but what is important to know when i
save you'll see yes it changed and it
just went back and only left one space
is
web pages or html
do not honor all those spaces you might
add with a space bar it's called white
space collapsing and so we can space
many lines
but it won't really be represented on
the page that is not how we add extra
space in html so again recognize white
space collapsing that it will not last
now something we can do is what's called
a line break and that can be inserted
inside a paragraph element so now i'll
put let me tell you how
and then i'm going to return remember we
don't have to have the opening and
closing tags on the same line for an
element we can nest other elements
inside of an element so i'm going to put
a break and that stands for line break
and then i'll put three dots and i'll
say let me tell you how
i learn more about web dev
and a period that looks good and now we
can put another break and i'll just put
three more dots
and say i plan
out my schedule
and one more line break
the three dots of course are not
required it's just what i'm adding here
and then i'll say i use
resources from
mdn which previously we discussed and
when i showed the definition of html we
were looking at the mozilla developer
network and that's what mdn is
so now if we save this file you can see
we've got line breaks and we're showing
each of these details on separate lines
okay let's scroll down and change some
of our second topic now so instead of
i'm ready to learn html let's change our
second sub topic to
i am let me capitalize that i am also
planning a
vacation
and now we can put some details about
that vacation in the paragraph
underneath this subtopic
and i'll say
i've been working hard
and really
need a
getaway period
and let's see if we want to add anything
underneath that yep let's add one more
sentence and what i'm going to do once
again is shift alt and the down arrow
and visual studio code will copy that
line down so
now we can just change the sentence here
and i'll say
i live in kansas
so i want to
visit
a beach
kansas is nowhere near the ocean so that
sounds pretty good so let's save that
and now we can see our sub-topic here
changed and we have a couple of
sentences
about planning the vacation now let's
change the my daily schedule subtopic at
the h3 to
places i'd like
to visit and i guess i could capitalize
that l on like there we go places i'd
like to visit
and now i'll highlight that paragraph
and say
i've heard
good things
about the
caribbean
sounds like they have warm water and
fun islands to visit okay so now we've
got some extra details here
and we can have more than one sub-topic
here so let's go ahead and do that again
shift alt and the down arrow to copy
that
and places
i want to avoid could be our next one so
places i want to avoid and here we can
put
anywhere cold
no
way with an exclamation mark okay so now
we've got some extra detail here in our
second area and this will allow me
to go ahead and show you the difference
between block level elements and inline
elements what we've been working with
here are block level elements notice
with every paragraph and every heading
they start on a new line that is a block
level element it creates space around it
which of course can be formatted in the
future with css
but it does not allow you to put another
paragraph inside of a header or a
paragraph
without creating that new line that
space so there will be
a return essentially in your content
when you're using a block level element
but when you use an inline element that
doesn't happen so let's look at a couple
of these first of all
we can say
i've been working really hard and i've
been working hard and really need a
getaway let's emphasize that really need
a getaway and one in line element that
we can do that with is e m and that
stands for emphasis that provides some
semantic meaning once again so now a
screen reader or other assistive
technology
or are just our browser overall knows
we're emphasizing this really need a
getaway so let's save and notice
really need a getaway is italicized now
we're not using it for the italicized
text again the formatting will come
later with css
but that is just the natural behavior of
using the emphasis
element as we wrap our text but it
provides that meaning now what if we
really want to emphasize that text it
has a strong meaning to us like our no
way here we don't want to go anywhere
cold well there is a
strong element we can use for that
and here let me grab the ending tag and
put it at the end of our no way
and now i'll save and notice it got just
a little bit bigger and bolder here as
far as the natural formatting of the
strong element but again this is an
inline element it's inside the paragraph
it did not create a
break in the line it did not create any
extra space around it so these are
inline level elements and the other
elements such as the header and the
paragraph we've been working with
are block level elements another type of
content we can add to our page are html
entities so they are things that are not
really the normal text we would type out
what for example if we wanted to
show a less than or greater than
symbol on our page right now html
interprets those as we're starting or
ending a tag so we can't just easily put
one of those on the page
likewise there are some other symbols or
remember when i talked about white space
collapsing if we need a little bit of
extra space there's an html entity for
that so i want to indent these three
lines with a little bit of space
and i can use the html entity i still
need the closing there here we go
and ampersand is usually what starts out
an html entity and now i'll type
nbsp and a semicolon
notice visual studio code recognizes
that right away
and if i save
i have spaced this line over just a
little bit
now i can add more than one of those if
i want so i'm going to copy that and i'm
going to add two more
and now save and our line is over even a
little further
so i will go ahead and select all three
of these
and i'm going to paste them right after
the line break on each line
and save and now we have indented with
some extra space
all three of these lines with these html
entities that create space but as i
mentioned there are other html entities
as well so let's scroll down here to the
bottom of our page
and after this last topic let's add
another hr
and now we'll type
and
lt
and a semicolon and that stands for less
than so if we save now look we have a
less than symbol underneath the final
horizontal rule here at the bottom of
the page
i'm going to go ahead and copy that
and paste
two more
and then i'm going to add
ampersand
copy with a semicolon and that will be
the copyright symbol then i'll just put
my name you can put yours and then i'm
going to add ampersand gt for greater
than and a semicolon and once again i'll
copy that
and paste
two more now if we save
you can see we've got our three less
than symbols we've got a copyright
symbol
then
your name or my name and then
three greater than symbols and we're
using html entities to create those i'll
provide a link to a list of html entity
codes in the resources for this tutorial
you may have noticed we've got a couple
of abbreviations
on our page we have the abbreviation for
kansas which is ks and we also have the
acronym or abbreviation for the mozilla
developer network here on our page so
let's go ahead and add
another inline level element
and that can help us with our
abbreviations
and that is abb
r but it doesn't really do it by itself
i'm going to go ahead and select mdn cut
it and paste it here in the middle of
the element
and this won't really provide anything
we also need to add the attribute title
here i can put the full
text mozilla
developer network
and save and now when we look at our
page it has some dots underneath mdn if
we mouse over
we get a tool tip that says mozilla
developer network now it's important to
realize this tool tip will not really be
available to screen reader and assistive
technology so
we don't want anything super important
for the understanding of the meaning of
the page to be in there so if we are
using abbreviation it's a nice thing to
have but it is really not accessible to
all assistive technologies so
it's it you can't have anything in there
that the page really depends on because
some of the people accessing the page
may not be able to read or see the
information that you provide here inside
the title attribute of the abbreviation
element let's go ahead and add that
abbreviation element for kansas as well
so abb r and then title
and i'll spell the state name kansas
and then i can go ahead and double click
on kansas control x to cut and i'm going
to paste it with ctrl v right inside the
element
save and now
dots are under the ks here on the page
and if i mouse over we get a tool tip
that says kansas let's put another
paragraph under places i'd like to visit
and i'll put
i can just type p and press tab as well
there we go and now i'll type
i've heard
good things
about
going here with a colon
and now i'm going to add
an address element
and we can put a location
inside of this address element and it
tells the browser that this is an
address or a specific location so i'm
just going to paste this in because you
don't need to see me type all of this
and i might easily have a typo here this
is margaritaville island in cancun it
sounds like a great place for a vacation
notice we've got a line break element
after each line except the last line and
if we save this and look at the page you
can see how the browser handles this
it is
just three lines of text it is all
italicized by default
and the browser knows that this is an
address and once again so would
assistive technology so an address
element
does provide
some semantic meaning as well to the
content within it now before we finish
this lesson about content there's one
other thing we can add to our code now
we won't see it on the page but it is
important to us
and this is an html comment
and so now you can see visual studio
code colored this differently at least
with the theme that i'm using and we can
leave a note for ourselves inside of our
code now notice this will not be on the
page but i will show you how the public
can see it so you don't want to put
anything in here that you don't expect
the public to be able to read
i'll put a to-do which is a common use
and i'll just put add
more places so it's a reminder to me to
add more places to the list of places i
want to avoid we save that and it
doesn't show on the page it's just a
reminder in the code or a note to
yourself inside of the code but i will
show you how the public can see this if
we right click
and choose inspect that works or you can
also press control u
either way will show your source code
now notice we've got a comment in here
that says add more places it's not
visible on the web page itself but it is
visible in the source code again you can
press ctrl u
to view this
now notice live server also injected a
comment here and it injected some
javascript so when we look at the
overall source code of what is live
we're seeing more than we even had
but this is a comment once again that is
not seen on the page and live server is
using a script element that we do not
see on the page either and that can
contain javascript for example so
just to let you know if you leave a note
for yourself
it can be viewed by others and finally
now that we've added all of this html
content to our page we once again should
go to the validator markup validation
service from w3c to check our file to
see if it is valid html or if we have
any mistakes choose validate by file
upload
and then click choose file
i'm going to have to probably go to a
different folder from the one that i
checked last so i'll go to html course
lesson three which is the file we are
working with choose my index.html and
open that here with the validator now it
has the index.html file uploaded and we
can click check
and we'll see if we have valid html so
this is valid it's green document
checking completed no errors or warnings
to show if you have errors or warnings
it should point out exactly where that
error is and you can fix that in your
html
let's look at how to create lists on a
web page lists are very useful and are
used in many places on the web so we
have three different types of lists
we're going to create today ordered
lists unordered lists and description
lists let's start out with recapping
here we've got visual studio code on the
left
and i've got the head element collapsed
so we had meta details inside of there
we can collapse that by clicking on the
arrow by the line and you see betw lines
between 4 and 11
are now collapsed
so we're working inside of the body
element to add content to the page
and this is visual studio code and i'm
running the live server extension you
can see down here it says port 5500
click to close server if you've
installed the live server extension it
may say click to launch or something
like that which would actually launch
your web page for you because that's how
you want to view it in a development
environment you don't want to just go to
file and open the file in your browser
you want to have that live server
running that simulates a web server if
you're not familiar with the live server
extension you can click on the
extensions logo here and instead of
searching for prettier that i have in
there you can search for
live server and you can install that
live server extension by ritwik day
right here
okay so we've recapped all of that
here's the file tree with our files i'm
going to hide that by clicking the file
explorer here so we can see more of our
code and we will add lists to our web
page today so i'll scroll down
to under the subtopic of my daily
schedule
and notice how we had these line breaks
and spaces here well we're going to
replace these so i'm highlighting the
first one and then i'm going to press
ctrl d that highlights the next one and
ctrl d again now it has highlighted all
three of those
and instead of this line break i'm going
to type li
and press tab
that adds a list item
but we haven't enclosed this in a list
yet and we definitely don't need the
closing list items here so once again
ctrl d ctrl d
so all three of these will be list items
but they need to be inside of a list too
so let's make this an ordered list by
starting out with an ol and i'll press
tab and we got the closing ol tag as
well that stands for ordered list as you
might expect and i'm going to actually
put the ol down here after the paragraph
tag the closing paragraph tag and i'm
going to cut with control x or you could
retype
if you want to and
i pasted the closing paragraph tag right
after the end of let me tell you how so
this is a shortened paragraph now and
the list will not be inside of the
paragraph
now we have our ordered list but that
also needs closing li tags so i'm going
to type the less than symbol and a slash
and visual studio code instantly filled
in the closing the rest of what is
needed there and i'll do that again for
the second one
and then i'll do that here for the last
one and notice we do have the
abbreviation still nested inside of the
list item here so now i'm going to press
ctrl s and save
and visual studio code reformatted that
just a little for me but look at our
page now that we've added this list it's
an ordered list and it is numbered that
means it's in or in order numerical
order one two and three notice these are
not this text is not enclosed inside of
a paragraph element so it's not creating
that extra space that a paragraph
element does they're stacked right on
top of each other there's still a little
bit of space but not like we have
between our paragraphs so that is an
ordered list we start out with the
ordered list element and then the list
items go inside it and each list item is
starting and then ending with the li now
let's scroll down and look at our
vacation area it says i'm also planning
a vacation
and we've got a places i would like to
visit area so after that let's go ahead
and add a ul which as you might guess
stands for unordered list
and we'll go ahead and cut that closing
tag and i want to put it after the
address here at the bottom
so this will be our full list now we
need to declare list items here in this
instance i'm going to go ahead and keep
the paragraph tags inside each list item
so we created an li there and i'll use
control x to cut
and close that first list item here for
the first paragraph
i'll do something similar here
got an li but the closing one is going
to be in a different spot because our
list item can have these tags nested
within it just like we nested the
paragraph here i'm going to go ahead and
nest the paragraph and the address
inside of the list item
here and so now if i save
and visual studio code reformatted my
code for me but notice here's the
beginning of the list item and we have
the end way down here after the address
so let's look at what this unordered
list looks like on our page and you can
see instead of numbers it has dots it
does have the extra space created by the
paragraph tags
and the address element still has the
content that it had before and still
formatted the same but notice our
ordered list and our unordered list are
both indented compared to being over
here flush to the left with everything
else we had like they were before so
similar in formatting from an ordered
list to an unordered list
and also realize that the really the
only difference is the bullet point here
in an unordered list versus the number
in an ordered list
the extra spaces were caused by the
paragraph element
inside of these unordered list items and
we did not use a paragraph element on
these ordered list items so the list
itself and the list items did not create
the extra space that was created by the
paragraph elements now let's scroll our
page we've got enough content we need to
make sure we're visiting the very bottom
here we want to add more under place i
want to avoid and i'm going to change
that to
places i want to avoid and let's go
ahead and remove our paragraph that says
anywhere cold no way
and let's add a description list here so
a description list as you might guess
starts with dl
now inside the description list there
are two different types of elements
instead of just an li like we had in our
other lists for a list item we have a
description term
and this description term could be
the place we want to talk about so let's
say the north pole
and now for the description term we need
to also have description details so
that's dd
and here i can put i here
this is
now let's go ahead and put our strong
emphasis back here
and i'll put cold and then our
exclamation mark so we have put a strong
emphasis on cold
and now i'll create an extra line here
just to space these apart another dt
i'll put the south pole
and then dd for the details description
details
and i'll say this is also called
and let's add one more
description term
this will be
mountaintops
and dd
for description details
and these
if i expel these
these are
also cold
now if we save
let's scroll just a little bit more so
we can see all of our content here you
can see our description list has a
different format than the ordered list
and the unordered list our description
term is to the left and then the
description details are indented to the
right but here is our full list of the
north pole south pole
and mountaintops we want to avoid all of
these places when we go on our vacation
with these new lists now added to our
file let's go ahead and create an error
on purpose just to see
if we have an error in our page when we
check it at our validator.w3.org
and here i'm going to choose file upload
and i may have to switch folders let's
see no i'm in the right one so i'll just
choose index dot three i think we're on
lesson four and i forgot to change the
file but i'll do that to make sure that
the github repo with all the source code
is correct so let's go ahead and check
this file
and yes we have some errors because we
created one specifically let's see if
that's our only error
as we have noted in the past
one error can create a cascade or a lot
of errors so now i've formatted this
correctly
let's go ahead and
load our file back up so we'll choose
file
we'll choose that index dot html file
again
and click check
now everything is okay document checking
complete no errors or warnings to show
so realize if you have an error it could
just be
one small syntax error that creates a
cascade of errors when we're checking
but this is a great way to learn and of
course look at the details of the code
and it's always a good idea to validate
your code after you write it to make
sure you don't have any syntax errors
let's move on to creating links on our
web page hypertext is the ht in html and
it's what links together everything on
the web it's really make what makes the
web work so well think about spider-man
or really any type of spider that's
throwing out strands of web and linking
things together that's essentially what
we're doing when we create hypertext
links we're linking the web together now
as we say link there can be some
confusion because notice here in visual
studio code on the left that i've got
link tags that we created
in the head part of the page that's from
lines 4 to 11
and these link tags are pulling in
resources from other parts of the web
whether it's something we have on our
server with our web page like this fav
icon
or
we could pull in something from another
part of the web like a font from google
fonts and things like that which we
haven't done yet but it's possible with
the link tag but that's not what we use
to link pages to each other i'm going to
collapse this head section by clicking
on the arrow over here by number four so
we have a little more room and now we're
looking at the body area in visual
studio code by the way i'm running the
live server extension and have our page
from our starter code that's available
for download at the github link in the
description
and i'm running that with the live
server you can see it running here it
says click to close the server shows
port 5500.
okay in visual studio code
let's scroll down a little bit and let's
add what is called an anchor tag that
will create a link to another page on
the web so in our list where it says let
me tell you how and we're talking about
the different things we do to learn web
development we have an abbreviation for
the mozilla developer network maybe this
would be a good place to go ahead and
link to the mozilla developer network
and we can insert a link
around this mdn abbreviation inside
the inline element that is the
abbreviation element so i'm going to
press enter here to start a new line
now i'll just type a
and this is well i guess because it's
followed by mdn it's not doing it so
i'll start out with the less than sign
and then a
and this is the anchor tag that i'm
starting but by itself if we just put
the anchor tag
while you can do that
by itself
it will not link to anything it needs a
specific attribute that tells it where
to go so i'm going to press enter here
and we have it surrounded by this anchor
tag we need to add the href attribute
and now we're going to reference an
address on the web so this is where we
would put that address in
over here in the chrome browser i have
the mozilla developer network open we
can see up here at the top it's
developer.mozilla.org
and then there's a slash after that that
gives the specific language for the site
i believe it will default to the browser
choice so i'm going to remove that part
go ahead and select the rest
and now that i have copied that with
control c i'm going to click here inside
of visual studio code
and put that address right inside the
href attribute now i am wrapping the
code down to another line so you can see
it all it doesn't go off the screen i
could expand visual studio code here and
now you can see the full
address without that line wrapping
so we're linking to the
developer.mozilla.org website with this
link
and we can save this
and now i'm going to go ahead and bring
visual studio code back to the size i
had it the code lines will wrap
but if we look at our code or our page
in chrome that should have now updated
because we're using live server you can
see we have a link and it turned purple
it's a little hard for me to see right
now but we can change that color in just
a little bit but that purple means a
visited link if you have not visited
that site it's probably more like a
royal blue or a bright blue color
and that means it's not visited yet and
those are the default colors for links
but something about this link that we
need to acknowledge this is the full
address to that website and it's a
specific address this is what you would
call an absolute reference this has the
full address for the web page where
we're going but when we link to
something that's already on the same
server as our page where we're hosting
our website
then let's go ahead and expand this head
section again notice we're not giving
an absolute reference we're giving
what's called a relative reference right
now we don't even have a slash here
because we know
this html5 dot png file is in the same
folder as our index.html file and the
same with this
main.css file it's in the same folder we
don't even need to provide a slash it's
not in another folder even so but it is
a relative reference and that's the
difference so we have an absolute
reference here to a place on the web and
then we can provide a relative reference
to something that's on the same server
that we're on so now let's go ahead and
create a relative reference to another
page
and i'll scroll down to do this we
haven't created the page yet we'll do
that next
but if you have your name here here at
the bottom i have my name where we have
the copyright symbol and in chrome i can
scroll down and we can see this at the
very bottom let's go ahead and link
with a relative reference so i create
that anchor tag that a tag and then href
and equals and let's link to about
dot html
and notice i'm
putting quotes around that file name
just like i did for the full address in
the absolute reference above and now i
want to put my name of course between
the opening and closing anchor tag
and now that will link this to the about
page that we haven't created yet i'll
save and notice now this is that bright
blue or dark blue that i was mentioning
earlier a link that has not been visited
this page doesn't even exist yet so we
need to create this page if you don't
have the file explorer open in the top
left of visual studio code you can click
that
and you'll see the files that we have
here in the file tree what i want you to
do is click on the new file icon
name this page about.html
now this is a good place to go ahead and
pause the video you can click on the
file explorer tree over here the file
explorer to hide the tree if you need
more room
but go ahead and create an about page
you know everything we've already
learned
from the index.html page so what i want
you to do is pause the video
create your own about.html
and then come back and i will create one
with you okay i hope that went well for
you i'm going to help you create an
about.html page now or you can watch how
i do it and compare to what you did now
i've been doing this for a long time and
i'm going to take a few shortcuts so you
don't have to see me type everything out
i'm at the index.html page i'm going to
press ctrl a
to select everything then ctrl c to copy
everything
click the about.html page again
and i'm going to paste everything in
with control v
now as you're learning how to do this i
think it's important that you type
everything but i don't want to take up
your time
and by having you watch me type
everything out so i'm just going to make
some changes here
the doctype is the same the html
element's the same and of course we have
a head section the meta tag for the
character sets the same the author's the
same
now this description meta tag
right here on line seven that could be
just a little different i'm also going
to press alt z to get this page to wrap
lines that are longer so now you can see
line 7 wraps down to a second line here
and we see the space to the left now in
this description i can change this just
a little bit and i'm going to say hi
i'm dave gray
this page is about me
so we've given an accurate description
for the page now and instead of my first
web page in the title i'm just going to
call it about me in the title
and now we still can use the same fave
icon and we're going to use the same
style sheet so this page will look like
the other page as far as the styles and
now we can change the heading for the
page and here i'm just going to say hi
i'm dave gray
after that i'm going to eliminate most
of what we see here on the page so i'm
going to highlight everything from line
17
all the way down to 63
i pressed shift and i clicked on my
mouse there and i've selected all of
that specifically
and now you can see we're left with the
horizontal rules and the space in
between and so now i'm just going to put
a paragraph that's not really about me
i'm just going to create some lorem text
and i can do that with a p element let's
try lorum
times
1. i just want one paragraph click that
there we go one paragraph of information
so it's still kind of formatted that
strange i'm going to go ahead and enter
before and after there we go
and now we've got that single paragraph
here anyway
this is a basic about dot html and we
have linked to it so now let's
downsize visual studio code back here
with the button you see right here the
square
not minimized but downsized it's not
maximized either
and now our link to the about.html
should work so i'm going to click that
link
and here we're on the about page and now
notice my name is this dark purple again
so we have gone to the about page that
we just created says about me here in
the top tab i'm going to click the back
button to go back to the original home
page here now back on the home page
there is a third type of link that we
can create and this is a link to an area
on the same page on the page we're
already on we can create shortcuts to
different areas of the page so we've had
our absolute references we've had our
relative references and now this is what
i would call an internal reference or
it's an anchor link directly to a
portion of the page that we want to go
to in order to do this we're going to
add just a little bit more to our page
so i want to click on the index.html
there we are i'm going to go ahead and
collapse the head again
and we've got a couple of topic areas
besides our big hello world at the top
so we've got the part where we're ready
to learn html and we've got the part
that we're discussing planning a
vacation
so we're going to organize this into
sections and there's a semantic html
element called section so i'm going to
type the word section press tab
and then i'm going to highlight the
closing tag of the section ctrl x to go
ahead and cut that out
i'll come down here before the
horizontal rule used as a divider i'll
paste that closing section tag in
and if i save yes we got some auto
formatting there so now we have our
section separated and we've got
horizontal rules in between i'll go
ahead and add a space between each of
those i'm going to do the same thing for
the vacation planning area so type
section press tab
go ahead and highlight the closing tag
control x scroll down
to the bottom where we're finished
discussing the vacations
and go ahead and paste in that section
now i'll save once again took advantage
of the auto formatting and we'll leave a
space
of course before the section here
between the horizontal rule in the
section and the same
at the end just so we can see it a
little better after the closing section
tag we have a space so now we've created
semantic html sections and that's not
all we need we also need to give these
sections an id attribute so i'm just
going to give the first id value for the
i'm ready to learn html area and id of
html
and then in the next section i'm going
to give an id attribute and that value
is going to be
vacation
and once again ctrl s to save or you can
go to the file menu
and choose save that way as well
now that we've done that we still
haven't created the links but we have
created
the destination for each of the links
that we want to create so now let's
create one more semantic html element
and to do that after our hello world
heading i'll go ahead and press enter to
come down a couple of lines type hr for
one more horizontal rule
and now between the horizontal rules i'm
going to type nav
and this is a semantic html element it
says we're creating a navigation area
inside the nav i'm going to type ul we
learned how to create unordered lists
already
and so now we've added an unordered list
and now we can add list items
and the first list item that we're going
to create is a link
and there it absolutely after i pressed
a and tab it knew we needed the href in
visual studio code so now it's waiting
for me to fill in this href now to link
to our html section here on the page
we need to add the hashtag
and then the id value so there's html
and so now we can put
learn html for this link
and then let's go ahead and add one more
a lowercase
press tab
and now hashtag
vacation
and we'll put here
planning a
vacation as a matter of fact let's
change this from learn html to learning
html
and now at the top instead of hello
world
i'm going to put my
goals for
the year
and now we have my goals for the year at
the top
and we've got learning html and planning
a vacation but i put them both in the
same list item and that's not what we
want so i'm going to go ahead and
highlight planning a vacation press
control x to cut that out
and now let's put it in its own list
item so li press tab we've got a new
list item
and we can paste that planning a
vacation if we save that looks much
better on our page even though the blue
isn't looking great on the darker
background we'll still change that in
the future
so now if we click learning html on the
page
it goes ahead and scrolls the page
directly up to the i'm ready to learn
html section we can click back and we go
back to where we were
and now if we click planning a vacation
it doesn't take us all the way to the
planning and vacation area because
there's no more content there's no more
space it can't scroll any higher but it
scrolled as far as it possibly could to
take us to that area
and once again we can press the back
button to go back and that dark purple's
not looking too well so we're going to
need to change those colors very soon
before we change any colors though let's
scroll down and create one more
link that's an internal link on our same
page here just to another area of the
page so at the very bottom
underneath our name and the link
to the about page let's go ahead and
return and add one more line here and
this will be a paragraph so we can press
p and tab
inside the paragraph let's start
an anchor
tag and there has the href attribute and
let's just link to the hashtag itself
now what we want to put in here for text
is back
to top
and we can save
now if we scroll down in our page here
we'll see the back to top link and if i
click it
it loads the page and takes us back to
the top
it's worth noting what we have up here
in the address bar of course live server
gives us our ip address which is our own
computer 127.0.0.1
nobody else on the web can see what
you're seeing this is just on your
computer
and then you've got a colon and the port
number 5500 where live server is serving
your page and we've got our index.html
file then notice you've got the hashtag
after that we could actually remove the
index.html and the index page will still
show by default just like you see right
here and now
once again if we click learning html
notice
in the address we get the hashtag html
when we click back it disappears if we
click planning to vacation we get the
hashtag vacation in the address bar and
if we click back it disappears in
previous tutorials i had mentioned
switching the theme over to this dark
mode that's easier on my eyes was
entirely optional so
if you're still using a white background
with black lettering
probably the purple and blue links look
just fine to you and you could just
leave it that way if you have switched
to the dark mode
theme that i have provided with some
basic css already let's go ahead and
make those changes so the links look
better as well so we're here in the
main.css file now in the file file
explorer
so we're just going to change the color
of our anchor tag and i'll switch that
color to a color named alice blue
after that i also want to change what
the link looks like when it's been
visited right now it's that purple color
so i'm going to change that color to a
light
gray
and
there's also another thing that we can
change and that is when you hover over
the link
or when the link is active
and then i'm just going to change that
color
to hashtag ee not three e e e there we
go
and save that and so now it's changed
the color of our links you can see this
is the light gray we visited these links
but when i hover over it gets a little
lighter
and so that looks good i think we've
visited every link here no we haven't
visited back to the top yet so you can
even see the alice blue color right here
and let's go ahead and visit back to the
top
and now
if we go back
you can see it's a little darker until i
hover over it so we've just changed
those colors we're not really covering
css yet we eventually will after we get
through all of the html but just for now
if you want those of course these will
be downloadable as well in the source
code let's go back to the index.html
file and let's hide this file explorer
by clicking on the icon in the top left
this is a good spot to talk about some
link naming conventions and things you
don't want to do so for now i'm just
going to use this link at the very
bottom that has my name as an example
and one thing you wouldn't want to do is
be instead of my name
just put in
the file text like this or what would be
worse would be a full url like
www.google.com
about.html and if i save this of course
that's not to google that's just ugly
and of course you don't need all of that
you can pare that down to just actually
a short description of what is there you
don't really want the full url there so
i'll put this back to my name
and there we go and another thing you
really don't want to do is say
this
links to
info
about because really that's redundant so
if i save that and we go this links to
info about and i didn't have a space
there i guess but either way
saying this links to is really redundant
just saying this is a link a screen
reader knows it's a link
you already know it's a link when you
see something underlined like that so
you don't need to say this links to or
this is a link about that's just
unnecessary you also want to keep your
link text as short as possible so
imagine if i had that same sentence
before this links to information about
dave gray and you just put the whole
sentence in the link that's way too long
just keep it to the exact topic so if
the page is about you as in our about
page just put your name in there for the
link you don't want the whole sentence
about that and now the very worst one of
all really would be to say something
to learn
more about me
comma and then instead of having your
name
right here for the text you put click
here we've probably all seen a link on
the web that says click here
that has no description whatsoever for
what's on the following page that's not
good for the context of what you're
linking to it's not good for a screen
reader as it tries to get context from
what the link says so really
a link that says click here and of
course you can imagine there could be
several links that say click here all on
the same page linking to different
things and that's just confusing so you
always want to avoid something like that
that says click here so once again i'll
remove all of this and we'll just go
back and we'll put our name here at this
link but i hope those pointers give you
some guidelines about naming just keep
it short and of course say what is on
the following page a very brief
description not a full sentence and
definitely not something generic like
click here okay i'm going to save the
index.html and we're going to go back to
the
about.html page and we'll add a few more
link types so we've got a section that
we're really saying this is about me
let's just add one more area here so we
can add another horizontal rule press
tab
and now let's add an unordered list
and inside this unordered list we'll
have list items
and this first list item should be a
download so we have a fave icon file
that we can offer for downloads so let's
say
download in
and then i'll give the anchor tag so a
href equals and now let's link to that
fav icon file that we have so that would
be
html5.png
[Music]
and now inside of this
we can put our html5
fave icon text
but this won't allow us to download the
file yet we need to add
the download attribute
and now this is a download link so if we
save this
and we go ahead
go back to the top over here in chrome
and well i guess not back to the top we
need to go ahead and click
your name or my name whatever you've got
on your page and that takes us to the
about page now we have
download an html5 icon and remember this
icon is in our folder over here as i
click the file explorer so we've got
html5.png
and that's what we're going to download
so if we click this link
we instantly get a download of that file
so that is a download link now let's add
another type of link so add another
list item here
and inside our list item now let's say
contact me at and now let's go ahead and
do another anchor tag with the href
and we can add an email link even though
these are not advised and i should say
before we add this these are not advised
because there are so many
spiders out there that crawl the web
really
search spiders if you will and what they
do could harvest these email addresses
and so these have kind of become a thing
of the past most people at a contact
form which will talk about forms in the
future instead of just putting their
email address directly in the page to be
harvested but
to add an email link you start with mail
two
and after that you would just have your
email address so i'll just put
random at
email.com
and if that's your email address i'm
sorry but it seems random to me
and then i can just put
my
email address
which would complete the sentence rather
than actually typing the email address
there as well
so i like something like that as far as
being descriptive contact me at my email
address and that's what the link is the
link is describing
your email address
okay then there's one other type of link
we can have oh let me save that by the
way and if you click this link that says
my email address it would ask you what
type of email client you want to open
these types of links with is what it
should do at least
okay the next link type that we have in
our list item will be
dialing a telephone number so now i'll
say
oops spell it right dial and now let's
put our anchor tag with the href and we
start out with tel for the telephone
number
and you could experiment with this
many examples i've seen add the plus
symbol
and i've also got it to work without the
plus symbol so i'll put the plus symbol
here
in the united states most phone numbers
are 10 digits so i would have like one
two three would be the first set of
digits then four five six
and the last set of digits 7 7890
something like that
and that is the telephone link so i
could say dial and then i could just put
my phone number just like i did with my
email address
and now especially on a mobile phone if
this was a mobile website this would be
very handy you could tap this and it
should open up the dialer if i click
this link now in chrome
it wants to make a call it's asking me
how to do it and pick an app to do it
because i'm here on my laptop but on a
mobile device this would probably open
up the dialer right away now let's look
at one more type of attribute here so
i'm just going to put one more list item
inside that
one more anchor tag with the hrep
attribute
and we're going to link directly to
google so we need an absolute reference
this would be https
colon slash www.google.com
and we can put the slash if we want to
as well
and this is an absolute reference but
the attribute oh and i haven't really
put in any text let's go ahead and just
put google up because we're not really
adding any extra context to this so the
attribute that we need to consider that
we haven't used yet is target and what i
want to do is have this open in a new
tab
so i'm going to use quotes then you put
underscore
blank
and save and now we have a link to
google
so
let me maybe add a little context here
i'll put
open google
and a new
tab period
save that and now we've got our link to
google if we click this
we opened up a new tab and i don't have
internet right now i guess i need to
check my connection internet's back up
and running let's click this link again
and there's google so we've opened it in
a new tab and all is well so i'll go
ahead and close that there's the one
that didn't work
and now we're back to our page now
there's one more type of link i want to
add before we finish today let's scroll
down in our about.html
and underneath our copyright line let's
go ahead and press enter
add a paragraph
and inside here we'll add the link that
we want to add so type a for anchor
and now the href is just going to have a
slash value what this does is link back
to the root of our website and that is
our index.html it's the page that loads
by default remember i had said we don't
even have to have the
dot
index.html
up here in the address it's just the
slash after the ip address and the port
here on our local server and if we had a
domain name like google.com well then
the slash would essentially be the home
it doesn't have anything else after the
slash it loads a page by default so
that's the same thing we're doing for
our website so here we can just put
back to home
and save this and now we have a link
that will take us back to our index page
so let's click this link
and we're back to our index.html but
notice
in the web address it doesn't even have
the index.html up here it doesn't need
that because it loads this page by
default this is the first page of your
website now that we've made all of these
changes to our web page and we've
actually added a second web page let's
go to validator.w3.org
and validate make sure that we don't
have any errors in our index.html and
ourabout.html we're going to choose
validate by file upload
and choose file
and for me i'm going to have to go into
my html tutorials folder click html
course and i'm in the 0 5 lesson here so
index.html
open the file and check
and document checking complete no errors
or warnings to show now we want to do
the same thing
for the about.html
and let's check that as well
and once again document checking
completed no errors or warnings to show
if you have errors or warnings of course
follow up on what it shows you here in
the validator and i hope you've learned
a lot about the different kinds of links
you can create in your html files
let's look at adding images to our web
page until now we've only worked with
text but html supports multimedia and
images are a big part of that so what we
want to do is go to visual studio code
that i have here on the left and i have
our project running here on the right
and we're using live server for that so
the live server has launched down here
and you can click to close the server or
open the server
if you don't have the live server
extension search for that here in the
extensions
find
live server
and that should pull up by ritwik day
and you just want to install that and it
can launch your page for you
okay going back to what we need we have
clicked on the file explorer
in visual studio code and we need to
create a folder to hold our image files
so i'll type img to name this folder
and it is a common practice to keep your
images for your web page or web pages in
a separate folder as you organize your
project
now that we've got that i'm going to
grab some images and paste those in so
we can work with them you'll be able to
download these images from the files and
resources that i share in the
description however at the end of this
tutorial i'm also going to go over some
resources where you can download your
own images that are free for use
so now inside this image folder i'm just
going to right click and choose paste
and paste these images in
let's look at what we've got i can click
on the vacation image
and i get this vacation image here and
notice at the bottom we can see the size
of the image it's 400 by
267. those are pixels
we can look at this html logo that we're
going to use it's 300 by 300 and we've
got an image of the caribbean as well
and it's 400 by 225. so i'm going to
collapse this now
and
we're going to use those in our html
code so now i'll click on the file
explorer to hide the file tree and this
all starts with the image tag so let's
scroll down in our html to where we want
to insert our first image in our page
we're going to put it right below
the paragraph that says this is my first
web page in the i'm ready to learn html
section okay let's start by typing img
and pressing tab and then visual studio
code will help us with that image
abbreviation
and it will automatically fill out the
rest of the image element now notice the
image element doesn't have a closing
element like we see here with a heading
or we see here with a paragraph
sometimes you will see it
with a slash like that at the end which
means it's self closing html does not
require that i should say html5 does not
require that however if you are using
this in the future in something like
react it may require that so that's just
something to be aware of right now i
won't put that in because html5 does not
require it and that's what we're
focusing on okay notice the image
element has a source attribute and an
alt attribute automatically the source
attribute tells html where to grab the
image we want so we start by typing the
folder name that we created now we see
the folder here image slash and i can
click on that and then it provides us
the names of the images that we have
well we want the html logo that i saved
so i'll just click on that and there is
the full relative path to our image it's
in the same project here and it's on our
local server
in this area so we don't need that
absolute url that would grab it from
somewhere else on the web so this is
once again a relative path to our folder
and then to the image then we have the
alt attribute now the alt attribute has
a couple of purposes
one is to help assistive technology for
those that may not be able to see the
image we are putting on the page the
assistive technology like a screen
reader will read the description of the
image so let's put html5
logo as the alt text but this also
makes this alt text appear on the page
if the image for some reason does not
load so first of all let's just save our
page and you'll see the logo
now appear on the web page and suddenly
our page got much more interesting it's
awesome putting images into our web
pages however let's go ahead and change
the file name so that it doesn't find
the image and let's see what happens on
the page
now we have a broken image icon but
notice our alt text appears html5 logo
so that is another purpose of the alt
attribute i'll fix that so we get our
logo back now there's other attributes
that we can and probably should use with
an image so one is title now we've seen
the title attribute before remember the
title
text that we provide here in the title
attribute is not accessible a screen
reader will not read it so this can't be
something that is very important that
everybody should know this is text
that can complement our image but it's
not necessarily
uh required the page is complete without
it but we can add some complementary
text here so i'll just put i am
learning html5
it doesn't have to be i don't even need
the period really it doesn't have to be
identical to the alt text at all this
should be complementary but now if we
mouse over the image we'll see the title
pop up that says i am learning html5 and
that's complementary a couple of other
attributes that
way back in the 1990s these were
required however for years these have
not been required but now they're coming
back and it's width
and height so if we define a width here
and we want to provide the same width of
our image now i saved this image with a
file name that tells me it reminds me
exactly the width and the height
and it's 300 pixels by 300 pixels so
i'll just put 300 if we just provide the
width
html will remember or shift
the image to match so the aspect ratio
stays the same so if i switch this to
200
and save notice it also adjusted the
height of the image however we want to
provide
both we want to provide the width and
the height and let's provide exactly
what they are
and i'll tell you why this is making a
comeback and why it is now recommended
to provide the width and the height even
though we can change this in the future
with css so i'm saying we provide these
but yes css may change
and override these values so why do we
provide them well it's a little
complicated but it's called cumulative
layout shift if you've ever gone to a
web page and you were getting ready to
click on something and then you saw the
page shift around maybe a pop-up ad
appeared or a banner ad and you clicked
on something that you didn't intend to
click because the button or the image
that you wanted to click suddenly moved
that is cumulative layout shift so we
provide the width and the height now to
tell the browser hey
this is going to take up some space here
and this is how much if we don't provide
that the browser shifts everything once
it figures out the size of the image now
once again you can still change the size
of the image make it responsive which
would adapt to mobile devices and
everything else with css so we really
provide this information with the width
and the height just to give the browser
an idea of the size and the aspect ratio
coming in so it just kind of prepares
itself and that helps just a little bit
it is now recommended by google
developers that we do provide the width
and the height in the image element with
our first image added now let's scroll
down and add a second image to our page
and we'll scroll down to our vacation
area place i'd like to visit let's
change this to places i'd like to visit
and
they've got i've heard good things about
the caribbean so this seems like a great
place to put an image of a caribbean
beach so once again we'll type our img
abbreviation and press tab
and then visual studio code helps us out
by providing the image element with the
source and alt attributes ready to go so
for the source once again type the name
of our folder press slash and now we get
the names of the images we have ready
i'm going to
choose caribbean
and then in the alt area i'm going to
type
caribbean beach
and now let's save and see what we get
on the page when we scroll down because
we have to scroll down a little ways to
see it and there is our caribbean beach
image
so now let's add a title attribute
that's just a little different than our
alt attribute just complementary text
and this is i
want to visit
a
caribbean
beach
and we'll save that now we're getting
closer but remember we should apply the
width and the height attributes as well
so let's click on the file explorer
because i didn't have the width and the
height saved in the name of this jpeg
file dot jpg notice the other image we
used was a dot png there are different
image file types and those have
different extensions so now i'll click
the
explorer up here we'll go back open the
image folder and i'm going to click on
the caribbean image
now when i do that in visual studio code
it shows the image and at the bottom i
can see is 400 pixels
by 225 the first number is the width so
i'm going to close this now
click file explorer to hide that so i
have a little more room and now i can
say
width equals 400
and the height
equals
225.
and if we save everything should remain
the same we've just provided these extra
attributes now i've noticed
that
this wrapped a little strange here in
visual studio code but know that the
width and the height are still part of
the image element that we started right
here
okay now that we've got that let's go
ahead and remove the in from the jpeg so
it will not find the image and make sure
our alt text appears yes we've got a
broken image icon but it says caribbean
beach and that is our alt text so i'll
fix that by putting the n back in the
name spelling it correctly and the image
shows up because now visual studio code
can find the file for us okay we had to
scroll down to see this image because
our page is long enough
that if we scroll to the top
we don't see our vacation area anymore
now this bottom of the page here you
could call it a crease if it was a
newspaper and a lot of the terminology
kind of goes back to newspapers and
magazines as we talk about layout
and so this bottom part
that defines the line
that anything below that we do not see
right now that's called the fold so
anything
after this area that we can now see is
called below the fold so anything below
the fold we have to scroll to see and
now we scroll to see this image well
there's one more attribute for this
image that i want to talk about and it's
the loading attribute
and if we provide loading and we can set
it equal to a value and there's two
possible values the first one
is eager but we never have to provide
this this is the value by default so if
we do not provide the loading attribute
the loading attribute is always there
and it's just set to eager we just don't
see it
but the one that we do need to provide
is called lazy
and what you want to do for performance
for your web page
is for any image that is below the fold
that is one you do not currently see
when the page loads you want to set the
loading attribute to lazy and that means
the browser will only load that image
when it knows it is about to show it
when we start to scroll
now firefox the web browser firefox is
much easier to demonstrate this in
chrome wants to display the image much
earlier so it right now this image is
close enough
to the area that we see that it will
still load this caribbean image
automatically that we have here so i
need to create some extra space and i
can demonstrate this to you by using
something called chrome dev tools that's
available in the browser so let's do
that now i'm going to scroll back up
above places i'd like to visit
to the hr area the horizontal rule that
we have going across right here before
the i am also planning a vacation
and i'll type an abbreviation
br for a line break and then i'll put
the asterisk for times and i'm going to
put 150. this emmett abbreviation that
visual studio code supports will insert
150 line breaks into our page there's no
way i would want to type all of those
individually but i can do it with this
abbreviation so i'll click that and
suddenly we have all of these line
breaks
if i save
and we don't see this change but now
there's a lot of space between the
sections and that's what i need to
demonstrate this so we've changed the
code i'm going to click the maximize
button here in chrome to bring the
browser all the way out and now let's
right click
and choose inspect and you could also do
this with keys
and it would be control shift and the
letter i all at once the control key the
shift key and the letter i i'm just
going to right click and choose inspect
either way we'll open up the dev tools
in chrome
and now that we're getting the dev tools
open
it will automatically open to the
elements tab and notice how if i
hover over an area in the elements now
it highlights those on the left in the
browser so here i've hovered over my
goals for the year and we can see that i
can hover over the section that
discusses html
and it highlights that section what we
want to do though is click the two
greater than symbols here at the top and
i'm going to choose the network tab
once it shows the network tab
you'll want your disable cache
to have the check mark
and that is because browsers know to
save images after they've loaded them
initially so they can reload them fast
but that is called the cache where it
stores the images that c-a-c-h-e
we want to disable that cache so we can
demonstrate this also
in this area right below the filters you
see all fetch slash xhr js css
choose the image all we are interested
in right now are the image files we
don't want to see the rest of the files
so once you've done all of that
we're going to go ahead
and reload the page so i'm going to
click the reload icon up here in the
browser
and we've reloaded and notice down here
we just see the html logo file that's
all that has loaded right now
and now as we scroll down as we get
close to the caribbean image file we
will see it load because it has
the loading attribute set to lazy so
only once we get close and i created a
lot of space here so i'm scrolling down
and fairly soon it should pop up there
it is
we don't see it on the page yet over
here but it's getting close so chrome
loaded it in preparation for us to see
it but what that really helps is that it
did not load the image right when we
loaded our page so that made our page
load faster it only loads these images
when it thinks it's going to need them
and that is lazy loading so now you can
click the x here in the top right to
close the dev tools then i'm going to
click the
maximize button again to get the browser
back to the size we wanted it i'll drag
it down here so we can see everything
and then over in visual studio code i'm
going to press ctrl z which is undo you
can also go to the edit menu and choose
undo but i'll do control z
and get rid of all those line breaks but
again if you want to demonstrate that
you can just type in br and then how
many of those elements you want in
visual studio code will recognize that
so that is a demonstration of a lazy
loading technique that helps your pages
load faster imagine if you had a page
that had a dozen or 20 or even 50 images
you wouldn't want the page to continue
loading until it loaded all of those
images so lazy loading is a very good
performance technique especially when
you're dealing with lots of images that
are below the fold now let's add a new
element to our page and it's something
we're going to wrap this image in so
i'll put it underneath the paragraph
that says i've heard good things about
the caribbean and i'm going to type the
word
figure and i'll press tab because figure
is an element now i'll highlight the
closing tag and press control x to cut
you can also get these options that i
use with the keyboard shortcuts in the
edit menu there's cut copy and paste so
it's ctrl x to cut and now at the end of
the image here i'm going to paste which
is ctrl v and now i've got the opening
and closing figure tags
i'll highlight the image here and just
tab it in as i'm used to seeing it so
the image is inside the figure element
now this by itself won't do much but it
is saying we've got a figure with an
image and we can add a caption and it
tells the browser
that the caption
big caption element
is related to the image which is better
than just putting a paragraph underneath
it the paragraph
while we could visually see it's
probably related to the image if it was
right under the image it's not telling
the browser or assistive technology that
it is a caption for the image this
spells it out for both the browser and
assistive technology that yes what we
put in here is directly related to this
image but it doesn't have to be
identical to the alt attribute of the
image although it should kind of be a
description of the image so i'll put
caribbean
beach
getaway here as our fig caption and now
it does show up on the page and notice
the image has been indented just a
little bit and once again we can change
all of the layout of the page and how
everything looks with css in the future
but this is just the
default behavior when we apply a figure
it's indented somewhat so we have an
image and the caption now let's go ahead
and add our last image as well and we
want to put that underneath margarita
island reserve riviera cancun an actual
resort in the mexican
riviera cancun area so we'll scroll down
here
and underneath the address we want to
add an image
of at least the cancun area because
that's where we're thinking about going
so image and we press the tab button and
we get the source and alt attribute
again so let's
type img that's the name of our folder
and slash
and now we've got our vacation image and
that looks good
and now we can put in the alt tag the
cancun
vacation for our vacation image
and now in the title
we can put something like
it's five o clock
somewhere because that's kind of related
to margaritaville and jimmy buffett
and he's famous for that saying and it's
five o'clock somewhere there's something
worth noting about this phrase we've got
single quotations here inside of our
double quotations now that's what's
possible if we had used single quotes
out here this would not be possible but
we can use single quotes inside of our
double quotes so this does work now
let's go ahead and save
and if we look at the page right
underneath the address for the resort
we're thinking about we've got our
caribbean vacation image and if we mouse
over we've got the
title it's five o'clock somewhere that
looks good but notice we don't have the
space or the indentation that we get
from the figure element so let's go
ahead and put a figure element around
this image as well so we'll type
figure press tab once again i'm going to
highlight the closing tag press ctrl x
underneath the image ctrl v to paste it
in and if i save i should get some auto
formatting and so now i've got the image
indented inside the figure and let's add
a caption here as well remember it's the
fig caption element so i'll press tab
and now let's put
a caribbean
vacation
image
so it's not quite the same as our alt
attribute it's not the same as our title
attribute but it's a nice description of
this image okay we're not quite finished
with our image it's easy to forget some
of these attributes that we might not
think about applying right away so
one we know we need is the loading
because this will absolutely be below
the fold so let's set that to lazy as
well and save and now let's click on the
file explorer again in the top left and
let's look at our vacation image and
find the dimensions
and we can see here at the bottom it's
400 pixels by
267 pixels
so now we can close that out
and click on the file explorer to hide
that again
and let's provide width and height so
the width is equal to
400 and the height
is equal to 267. so now we've provided
all the correct attributes that we need
for this image
and everything looks good here on the
page
one more thing i want to add about
figure figure is not just for images so
let's scroll up here in vs code back to
our html area
and we do have
our html logo right here underneath this
is my first web page we'll scroll back
up to this area here on the page as well
and now we can add a figure underneath
this image
so i'll type the word figure again
and now let's add a fig caption first
the fig caption element needs to either
be the first thing inside of a figure or
the last thing it can be either or so
here i'm going to type
in example
of html5
code and that will be our caption so
let's save that much and we see that
here but really we have no content
inside of our figure yet so let's go
ahead and add some content and i'll add
a paragraph which is a block level
element we've discussed that in the past
block versus inline
and now for the text of the paragraph i
want to put that inside of an inline
element that will not create a line
break and it's a code element code this
element code helps you actually display
code if that's what you want to use you
can use other elements inside of it
though so if i want to display html code
i can't simply put an h1 element because
then it applies this element to the page
we need to go back to what we learned
about html entities to provide
the less than sign which is an ampersand
lt with a semicolon then i could type h1
and then ampersand gt with a semicolon
for the greater than symbol and now i'll
put
hello world
with an exclamation mark and then i'll
do the
less than html entity again and then a
slash h1 and then the ampersand
gt semicolon which is greater than
in a semicolon and now if we look at the
page
we have got an example of some html code
printed directly to our web page so this
is another example of how to use a
figure element it can contain other
content such as a code sample and you
can have a caption at the top just as
easily as you can at the bottom of the
figure okay our code for the lesson is
complete but i do want to show you some
image resources but before we can do
that we need to validate our code with
the validator once again so i'm going to
grab this and make it just a little
wider so the validator shows up better
here remember we're at validator.w3.org
we want to click validate by file upload
click choose file make sure you're in
the correct folder once this folder area
opens up and i'm in the lesson six
folder and then i'm going to choose the
index file that we were working in and
choose open and from there i can choose
check
and it should check the html it says
document checking completed no errors or
warnings to show that's what you want if
you do get an error warning it should
tell you what line it's on in your code
and you can refer to visual studio code
find the line and fix the error that it
is telling you about so once again
validate your code before you finish
before finishing this image lesson i
wanted to share some resources that i
use now there are many resources out
there so these are just a few and i'm
sure you can find others as well first
there's this article that has 21 of the
best placeholder image generators using
placeholder images is very common
practice when you're laying out a page
and you're not sure the images you want
to use yet what you can do is take a uh
url like this from
placeholder.com
and put it in as the value of the source
attribute in your html image tag
and then it will generate a placeholder
image until you find the image you want
to put there some of these other image
generators actually provide pictures
like the second one on the list called
phil murray provides random pictures of
the actor bill murray but it works in
the same way you put the url in
for the source attribute value in your
image tag and then you will get a
picture of bill murray from this image
generator okay the next several sites
are just great places to download
freely
usable images as it says right here
these are licensed for free use it's
important to download and use images
that you actually have the usage rights
to so
this is a good way to do that find them
on
unsplash.com is my favorite you can also
go to pexels.com as you see here very
similar site you can also go to
gratisography.com
and this site has unique and kind of
funny pictures so that's kind of neat
too
and you never know what you'll see on
these the next one is pixabay.com
very much like the previous ones i
showed you from there i want to suggest
some free image software it's called
orphan view i've used this for years
it's just really lightweight software
easy to use and you can load in an image
and resize it and that's what i usually
use it for you can also crop images with
it i'll pull it over here as i have an
instance of orphan view open already
you can see i've got in this large
picture of the caribbean beach but you
can go to the edit menu
and you can see different options that
are here such as the crop
and of course we'd have to select an
area to do it but in the image menu
there is a resize resample
and here you can see you've got the
dimensions of the image but i can resize
this it's a huge image right now at
5464 pixels wide
i'll take it to say 400 pixels
and it stays in sync so it keeps the
aspect ratio and now we're at
225 for the height so you see the
current size and then the new size i'll
click ok
and it brings it down to a much smaller
nicer size easy to save as well as a new
name
and a great little software to use from
there i also recommend
canva.com now disclosure here there is a
paid subscription to use this site
however i believe they have a free
account that you can at least get some
of the features or try it out so
canva.com is good
after you've got your images and even
after you have resized your images to
the smaller size that you would probably
use on your web page it's also a good
idea to drag and drop them into
tinypng.com i believe this also comes up
if you type in tinyjpg.com
but it will compress the images and they
will still look good but they get a
smaller file size so they load to that
web page faster which is always
important so all of these resources are
great and i will put links to all of
them in the description below
documents need organization and our html
files are no different html achieves
document organization with semantics in
this lesson we're going to improve our
code with the semantic html layout let's
get started i've got visual studio code
here on the left with our index.html
open and on the right i have got our
index html page displaying and we're
using the live server extension for
visual studio code to display that page
and you can see it's launched down here
you can click the close or open the
server you can search for that extension
over here at the extensions icon if you
do not have it again it's the live
server extension okay so we're adding
semantics to our index html page now
we've already added some so let's
highlight what we have done already as
we've built this page out over the
lessons the main thing that we have done
correctly is add a hierarchy of headers
you only want one h1 per page
and this should be an outline much like
you would have an outline for an essay
or any type of paper topic you would
write so this is your title for the
whole page essentially and from there
you can have multiple h2 headers which
is one level down in the hierarchy
and they would define subtopics and then
beneath that you could have h3 headers
if there was a subtopic of a subtopic
and so on and that continues to h6
although you really don't want any more
than about three
levels of headings on a page so h1 h2 h3
would be the ideal way to have a page
laid out after that we need to consider
some things about semantic html writing
semantic html helps us quickly see or
read the different sections in a web
page and navigate to those sections now
we've already added a nav element to our
page and nav elements are semantic
elements so this says we have a grouping
of links here and we can see that on the
page with learning html and planning a
vacation we have a grouping of links
here that will help us navigate to the
rest of the page
we also have an hr which stands for
horizontal rule in the past i believe i
might have said these didn't really have
a semantic meaning but they do they're
currently viewed
as semantic elements and it means that
there is a topic change so something is
changing and of course we have a couple
of topics on our page and we have
horizontal rules between those in the
future as we learn css we may want to
remove the horizontal rules we see here
that divide our navigation and our
heading for the page and replace those
with lines that we can create with css
because we're not really separating
topics here although it doesn't hurt to
have these horizontal rules in place at
this time and the main thing to convey
about semantic html is the word semantic
that means it provides meaning as the
nav element says hey this is a
navigation area or the h1 element says
hey this is a heading we can also get
that from other parts of the page we
added section elements that say this is
a new section so they provide additional
meaning
rather than just
a generic
divider and we will talk about what a
generic divider is later as well now in
addition semantic html makes our pages
accessible to screen readers and other
assistive technology and that is very
important as we create pages now while
we've added some semantic html already
let's add the three big areas that most
consider for pages the first is not a
head section but a header for our page
now we have a heading which is the title
of the page
but we can wrap this in a header element
and there can be more than one header
element per page however it needs to
follow the heading hierarchy so imagine
if we had a social media site now every
post whether it would be a blog post or
a post like facebook or instagram every
post could have its own header and it
might have a subtitle in that post as
well
but this is a header now for our full
page so this would be at the top level
of our page with the hierarchy here of
h1 which is the heading for our page
notice we've also included the
navigation inside of our header and we
can go ahead and remove this horizontal
rule and i think it will be just fine we
don't need the semantic meaning of a
change topic there and i think it's
going to look okay without the line as
well so let's save this now
and we can see live server updates our
page immediately so we can see the
change and really all we see visually is
that our horizontal rule is removed
however we have added some extra meaning
to our html here now that this is the
heading or the header section for our
full page now the next element we want
to add is the main element now there can
only be one main element per page and by
definition that would make sense you can
only have one
main area for content
per page and so we'll start here and
it's going to include our sections that
we've created so i used ctrl x to cut
the closing main element tag
and i'll scroll down to where our
second section ends before our area here
at the end and i'll paste
the closing main element and save and we
can see visual studio code reformatted
for us so now we've got the main
element wrapping
our two topic areas of vacation
and of html so we've added a header and
a main element now one other thing we
can add for our page is a footer now
just like the header there can be more
than one footer per page
and that might be a footer for a blog
post or a footer for a social media post
but this is the footer for our
entire page in this example once again
ctrl x to cut that closing tag and i'm
going to wrap everything we have here at
the end in the footer
one other thing i want to add just
because i didn't do it before we
validated our page throughout the other
lessons and it's not an error it's not a
problem but i want to include this
information here about the copyright i
want to include that in a paragraph
element so
i'm going to make sure that's lowercase
well am i getting a capital there we go
and then i'm going to once again
cut the closing tag and put it
after the content and save it gets
reformatted it really doesn't change the
look i just wanted both inside that
paragraph and that might help in the
future when we want to format this area
as well with css so now our document has
been outlined into three major sections
we have a footer a main area and a
header and then inside the header we've
already discussed we have a navigation
element that is also
semantic html our list is also semantic
html we know right away that this is
providing a list and this would be
identified by assistive technology as
well now there can be more than one nav
element per page so we might have a nav
area in the footer footers often have
links to other areas
of a website now we've only got a couple
of links in our footer and one goes back
to the top and the other does go to our
about page however it's not a grouping
of links where we would organize if we
had several other things here i might
consider a nav and if you do have more
than one nav element per page it's
important that they are labeled so
assistive technology knows
which nav is which and here we can do
that with an attribute called arya dash
label
and then we can set it equal to
something that clearly says what it is
like primary
navigation and now we have labeled
our nav as the primary navigation area
if you did include a heading in the nav
element which is not required but if you
did you could link to that so you could
have an h2 here
and then in the h2 we might put
primary
navigation if i can spell it there we go
and now let's give this an id
and here we'll give the id
the same value primary
navigation and then here instead of arya
we would say
arya labeled by is the correct attribute
here now we're looking at
our primary navigation value
and it's saying hey it's labeled by this
value that's in the h2 so you can link
these together with an aria labeled by
pointing back to the id
of a heading however since we're not
going to have an h2 in our nav
i'll go ahead and remove that and you
can just choose the aria
label attribute and set that equal to
primary navigation which is equally
accessible to screen readers and other
technologies okay let's scroll down into
this main area previously we broke our
topics html and vacation into sections
which are semantic html tags however
there is a more appropriate tag now that
we kind of have an idea of how our page
is laid out because these are
areas that could be
on their own maybe they would each have
their own page but much like a social
media post or a blog post some type of
article you might think there is an
article element so i have highlighted
this section and i'm going to type
article instead and i believe we'll find
that vs code changes our closing tag
immediately yes and it was already
changed to article
so
instead of a section let's call this an
article because it clearly has its own
topic and now let's do the same for our
other section based on vacation so we
can highlight it
change it to article and we'll verify
that the closing tag is also article
and yes it is right here so now we have
two articles instead of sections now
there is sometimes a debate about which
should be used and it's really not
clearly defined if article or section is
the proper choice they would both pass a
validator check so really the way i look
at it is an article has a clear topic
where a section is more generic you
might use a section just to actually
create a little section in your code
whereas an article has a clear topic
that the area is about so now inside of
the article we could create other
articles but now i want to go ahead
and add a couple of sections inside of
our html article so as our article
begins we've got the heading which is h2
and it says i'm ready to learn html and
then we have a paragraph saying this is
my first web page that's fine let's go
ahead and add the section after that
point
and now once again i'll press tab to get
both the opening and closing tags i'm
going to highlight the closing tag
control x to copy it i'm going to bring
it down here to just underneath the
figure and that's where we'll end this
first section i also want to go ahead
and add a subheading here which is an h3
and i'll just make this html5 as that's
what the section is about
and now our section has the subheading
html5 it has the html5 logo and it has
our figure that has our code sample of
html5 that all seems related
now let's add another section and this
is the my daily schedule section so
lowercase again is what i prefer
and so we'll have section and the
closing section tag i will cut that and
i'll put it here at the end of the list
before the closing article tag so now we
have two clear sections inside of our
article and they both have headings that
are h3 so we're at the third tier of the
heading with the h1
being the heading for the overall page
the h2 being the heading for the article
and then the h3s being the headings for
the nested sections within the article
so we're keeping our hierarchy in place
underneath the list we can add another
element and just a little more content
let's call this an aside this is a
semantic element and if you think about
how a web page is laid out oftentimes
you think of an aside as the sidebar to
the page but it could also just be
another section of complementary text
that is not
as important as what's in the main
section or article that you are putting
it inside of and that's what we'll do
here and then i want to use some other
semantic elements just to demonstrate
how they work so now i'm going to add a
detail semantic element and inside a
details element you want to add a
summary element now the summary if this
was a product we might just put warranty
information in here as the summary here
i'm going to put something that's more
like a question and it will display how
the details and summary work so i'm
going to say
guess the number
of hours
i code
per day as our summary now underneath we
can put the answer to this question and
now i'm going to put
i start at
8 a.m and i write
code for
let's say three hours
every morning
and we can save that
i'll scroll up so we have it up here
towards the middle of our page
and now let's scroll up here and let's
look at what we have on the page because
the rest of our semantic changes really
didn't change the appearance here
but this where we added this new content
notice we're not seeing this paragraph
at this point we just see guess the
number of hours i code per day but it
has this little arrow next to it if we
click
on this
then we see the answer
so that's a nice little addition that
this html element adds and again these
are all semantic elements so the aside
has some meaning that it's complementary
text it's not as important as what's in
the rest of the article
the details and the summary work
together so this could once again
provide details about a product say
warranty information something else a
return policy whatever but you could
also use it kind of as a quiz here where
you have a question and an answer let's
go ahead and add just a couple of more
semantic elements to this one is what we
can do with a highlighter just like you
might use a highlighter on a piece of
paper there is an element called mark so
i'm going to mark what i want to
highlight here in the text
and by including it in the text you know
it's an inline element and not a block
element
so now if i save that we have
highlighted
number of hours
now inside the answer we're looking at
some time here we have 8 am and we also
have a duration of three hours we can
add some meaning to that in the text as
well
and we can provide a time element then
we need a date
time attribute
and for the date time attribute value i
want to put in the actual hours it
accepts several values so this would be
o 800 on a 24 hour clock
and now let's put the closing time
element after the 8 am here
and notice if i save this right now
and show this it does not change what 8
am looks like at all but once again it
provides meaning in our html for
technologies that are reading it
especially those assistive technologies
but it could also provide some meaning
for the browser itself now also it says
as i write code for three hours we can
provide a time element for the duration
too so we have time once again with the
date time attribute and now we'll put in
a different value because there is a
value for duration i'm going to put this
closing
tag at the end of the three hours now
let's look at the value for duration we
would put in
pt3a
and remember there is a link in all of
the html resources that i link to in the
description there is a link that shows
all of the html elements so you can look
up for example the time element on the
mozilla developer network that's the mdn
site and you can look at all the values
that could be accepted for the date time
attribute okay let's save this and move
down to our vacation area where we also
want to add two sections i think these
are clearly defined already where we
have sub headings for places i'd like to
visit and really we have a subheading
for places i don't want to visit i
believe so here let's go ahead and add a
section again lowercase
and i'll take that closing section tag
highlight it ctrl x to cut i'll scroll
down here
and we'll add that before the next
subheading so
there we go and save that and of course
it reformats again
now i'll add a section element
and put the closing after we finish our
places i want to avoid section and that
would be at the end of our description
list
and we can save that now we've got two
sections inside of this article as well
and really once again it doesn't change
the look but it does change how the
browser interprets and it definitely
adds a benefit for assistive technology
now before we look at our document
outline with these changes i want to
quickly discuss and i'll just do it here
by this comment where it says add more
places two different elements that you
want to avoid as you're learning html
and then later on
you can use them as we possibly get into
them with css but there is a div in an
older html code you will see divs
everywhere sometimes you still do
when those people that have been using
divs are used to still writing them and
they just continue what they've been
doing in the past however there is no
semantic meaning to a div think of a div
much like a section without the semantic
meaning it's just stands for divider and
really you can put them anywhere but if
you do
you really have to do a lot of work to
get them to convey meaning you have to
add additional attributes that help
assistive technology interpret these
elements because they have no meaning as
is they are block elements so
a very similar element that is an inline
element if we just wanted to wrap a word
or two in a paragraph in an element
is span
we'll definitely use some spans as we
learn css however once again they have
no meaning whatsoever by themselves they
don't change or add any value to your
code and we would use them possibly to
apply some css styling to some words
that we would highlight around span so
we really want to avoid both of these
elements as you learn html really work
on using semantic elements and then
when you understand what semantic
elements are and how to use them and
then occasionally when just no semantic
element is the correct choice
that is the time that we actually should
use divs and spans so i'm going to
delete those for now
and save our document and now i'll just
scroll our code up to the very top and
i'm going to do the same for our page
over here on the right now what i want
to bring your attention to i'm going to
maximize the browser
and we're going to go to the chrome web
store and look at an extension we can
add and that extension is html5
outliner so search for that
you'll find html5 outliner you can click
on that and i've got it installed
already so
mine says remove from chrome yours would
probably say install here and it will
look at our semantic elements and make
an outline of our page so let's check
that out okay i'm going to bring our
page back down to the size we had it
down here to the bottom now once you've
got that extension installed you may
have to restart your version of chrome
to get it to work but here we go click
on html5 outliner and look we have got
an outline of our current page so we've
got our heading hierarchy correct with
my goals for the year an untitled nav
that's okay we didn't put a heading in
there like i said we could have put an
h2 it's just saying we didn't have one
but a nav doesn't require one but
remember if you do have more than one
nav element per page then you do need to
at least appropriately label that for
assistive technology okay now we've got
another section this is our article i'm
ready to learn html and that's our h2
heading
inside the article remember we have two
sections we have the html5 and my daily
schedule and then we have an aside and
this aside was inside the second section
it's also untitled which is okay and a
side does not have to have a heading but
it just notes that as it's untitled here
if you added a heading inside of the
aside say an h4 then it would of course
appear there now we've got our other
section this our other article actually
this i am also planning a vacation that
was an h2
and then these are h3 headings so you
can see how important the headings are
the heading hierarchy if you don't get
any other semantics correct in your page
that's the one thing to really
understand is the heading hierarchy of a
page but all of these other semantic
elements definitely help outline your
page and add meaning avoiding these is
the biggest mistake you can possibly
make as you are constructing an html
page okay now that we've looked at our
outline let's once again validate our
page i'll pull this over just so we see
a little bit better i'll click
file upload we're at validator.w3.org
and i'm going to click choose file i
have to make sure i'm in the right
lesson
folder i am not so i need to go into
html course
lesson 7
index.html just make sure you upload the
index.html you were working on for this
lesson
click check and we'll see if we have any
problems if you have a problem it will
show here it should tell you what line
and what the problem is but we're good
to go document checking completed no
errors or warnings to show
let's add a table to our web page table
structure tabular data that is data
that's made up of rows and columns we
often see this with schedules
statistics in sports and many different
types of data flight schedules for
example
and what we don't want to use tables for
are an entire page layout back in the
90s and early 2000s it was very common
to use a table to structure your entire
html page so you may see some old code
that does that but we do not want to do
that we want to stick with semantic html
and in the future you'll learn css and
we'll design our page layouts with
semantic html and css not tables okay
tables do really need a little bit of
css to look kind of accurate however we
can start creating a table without css
so let's do that now i'm going to scroll
down in our html file and we want to get
to this section that says my daily
schedule the subsection and then we
describe the daily schedule a little bit
and we even have the aside here that
says guess the number of hours i code
per day so we want to put some of this
in a chart or a table if we will not
really a chart i guess so
here we go with a line break
and underneath this break we'll put a
table element
inside the table element i want to
scroll up just a little bit so we can
see this better inside the table element
i'm going to type a tr element which
stands for table row
and inside the table row we put our data
cells and those use td elements which
stands for table data okay the first
thing i'm going to do now is start a
time element which is going to have a
date time attribute
we'll set that equal to 8 am
and inside this we'll put 8 am
notice i've pressed alt z already which
has my code wrapping down to the next
line if it would extend further so if
your code is extending outside of the
window here in visual studio code just
press alt z and it will wrap to the next
line
i'll put a hyphen here
and then another time element with a
date time attribute
i'm going to set that equal to
11 am and i'll put 11 am here so now we
have 8 am to 11 am and our first data
cell and then i'll put the activity in
the next data cell and here we'll put
write code
now i'm going to highlight this full row
and then press shift alt and the down
arrow and it will copy that down so i've
created another row quickly so we can
just
edit some of the information here so now
i'll start at 11 am
and then i'll switch the next one to 12
pm
and so there's our one hour for lunch so
here we can put
eat lunch now let's do this one more
time or i'll highlight the row
and then press shift alt and the down
arrow
and now we'll have our afternoon time
here so this is a 24 hour clock that we
need to be aware of as well so we'll
start at 12 pm
and now this will be 17
and this would be 5 p.m over here
so now from 12 p.m to 5 p.m we can put
in another activity and i'll just say
study for
other courses
and we'll save now let's scroll down
over here in our html and look at the
table we have applied no css so we can
see the columns with the times on the
left and the activities on the right but
it is a little hard to make out that
this is a table so i want to add just a
little bit of css to help our page out
i'm going to click on the css file that
we've linked to our project scroll down
to the bottom
and just paste in just a little bit of
css for now this will be available in
the files and once i save that you
quickly see how it applies to the table
this looks much more like a table 8 am
to 11 am write code and we can see
clearly each time block and each
activity i'm going to go back to the
html file but i also want to expand the
browser to highlight something that
happens here in the code i'm going to
right click on the table and click
inspect this will open dev tools and it
should be showing the elements now if we
highlight the table over here in the
elements tab in dev tools you can see
it's highlighted on the page notice all
the orange to the right that is margin
that is not table so the table doesn't
expand to the width of the page it only
expands
based on the content inside the table
that is different from some other
elements like the paragraph element
notice how it expands for the full width
of the page
or the ordered list element that we have
here it expands for the full width of
the page the same with the aside element
so it's worth noting that the table is
different from a lot of other elements
that automatically take up the full
width of the page the table element only
expands to contain the content that is
within the table okay i'm going to close
devtools resize chrome once again so we
can see our code here on the left
and what we are missing from a table
are headers for our columns we clearly
have a time column and an activity
column so let's add that by adding a row
at the top of the table
we'll start with the t element again tr
element and then inside instead of td
for table data we have th elements for
table header so we'll have time
and then we'll also have
activity and now if we save that notice
that the time and activity are formatted
just a little differently and i did not
do anything different for these headings
in the css
what we have is a centered
heading and it is in bold and that is
the default styling that is applied to
table headings now what if we had some
data that needed to take up two columns
in our table so in other words one cell
would span the width of both columns we
can do that so let's add a row at the
bottom
and inside the row we'll put one data
cell and i'm going to put free time
inside here for data but there is an
attribute called call span and we can
set this equal to 2
and this will take up the width of both
columns okay now i'm going to remove
this call span
and let's put a data cell before free
time here
and here we'll say inside of this data
cell
let's put all
other
times
but for the attribute on this cell let's
put a row span which also exists
and we'll have this take up two rows so
now let's put another row underneath
and in this row we'll only have one data
cell
and here we can put
sleep
now if we save you can see our all other
times is taking up two rows and now we
have free time and sleep on the right
now our previous lesson covered html
semantics which definitely helps
structure a page and tell the browser
what the page is about and it also helps
assistive technology like screen readers
navigate a page for those that do not
use a mouse for example to navigate the
page so let's scroll up and start adding
some semantics to our tables because
that is also possible
underneath the table the first element
we want to add
is a caption
so we add the caption and we can say
what the table is about and that would
help someone navigating with a screen
reader decide if they really want to
navigate the rest of the table or just
skip over it and clearly we can also do
that visually so let's just put in my
daily schedule like the same title we
have for the sub section above in the h3
and as soon as i save that you can see
now the caption spans both columns
already and is centered and we didn't
have to add a column span for that to
happen that automatically happens with
the caption after that we can clearly
define sections of a table much like we
do sections of a page so let's start out
with the header and this is the t
head which stands for table head now i'm
going to go ahead and highlight the
closing tag press control x to cut
and add it underneath the end of the row
and we can save and here you see the
full table head clearly defined it
doesn't change the appearance at all but
it adds semantics to our table
likewise there is a t-body element for
the table body so i'm going to once
again highlight the closing tag press
control x to cut
scroll all the way down to the end of
our table the last row but before the
closing tag of the table
and paste the t body tag
so now we've got a head and body section
for our table we can also add a t foot
section so now inside of the footer i'm
going to put another row
and inside the row i'll put a data cell
and i'm going to give this a column span
equal to two
well i didn't get the row or the data
cell started there we go
now we go call span
equal to two
and inside of here i'm just going to put
a statement but you could put something
in the footer that say totals up all of
the columns if you had a ledger that was
tracking account numbers or expenses or
say you had
sports stats or something like that or
anything else that would need totaled up
that would be a good place to put it is
inside the footer i'm just going to put
a statement about our schedule i'm going
to scroll up before i add the statement
but here i'm just going to put
and that's what i do
every everyday comma
five days a week period just eat
sleep
code
and recharge
i'll save
and now we can see our footer is
spanning both columns and we've clearly
defined the semantics for our table now
with a header a body and a footer now
another question you might think of is
what if the row needs a header as well
it needs some definition so if we can
have a heading for our column what if we
need another kind of official title for
each row as well well we can do that as
well so let's scroll up here to the top
and in our header we'll need to put an
empty
square or an empty cell
and we can do that we'll just add
another th and inside of here we need to
put ampersand nbsp with a semicolon this
is an html entity if you remember when
we covered html entities in a past
lesson and that just puts a little small
space inside of the cell now that we've
added that we can add headings to each
of the other rows so
we'll have a th here for the first row
and i'm going to put
morning
and then in the next row we'll add
another th and i'm going to put
break
and in the next row
th and i'm going to put
afternoon
next row
th
and this is evening
and in the final row
well i guess not the final row that
would be the footer but this would be
the final row with a row heading
and i'm going to put
knight so if we save this we can really
see how our table has changed but notice
we didn't change the call span yet for
the footer so we've got an empty square
here as well here's the empty square we
defined but we didn't plan on this so we
better change our call span for the
footer
to three because we now have three
columns and if we save that looks much
more like it and you can see when we
added the row span and we came down to
this final row
and we only added a first and a third
column
we didn't have to specify that this was
the first and this was the third it
automatically knew that because the
second column in the row above is the
one that had the row span of two now our
page is looking pretty good over here as
far as the table goes but we need to add
just a little bit more for semantics and
we need to go back and start at the
header to do that so i'll scroll back up
and here we are in the t-head area of
the table and for each heading that we
have on the page each th except this one
that has a space in it we need to
provide a scope
and that says how it relates to the
table so this would be scope equals to
call which stands for column
and i'm just going to copy that because
we need to add that to the next one
and so time and activity both apply to
the columns so as you might guess when
we get down to the next part in the body
where we get to the row headings
i can paste this in but i need to change
column
to row
and i'll copy this and we need to apply
this to each one of the row headings so
now at break
and then we had
afternoon
evening
and finally night and if we save that
once again the semantics don't change
the look on the page but we have really
helped assistive technology navigate our
table now this is the easier way to do
that with scope however that you may see
that
accomplished in another way and that is
providing an id
for each header so if we had an id
and set that equal to time
and then we had an id
let's say in this row or this row up
here with morning and we set it equal to
morning
then in the td we would have to give the
headers attribute and specify both so we
would say time
and morning i find it much easier to
just provide the scope instead of ids
and then having to add a headers
attribute to each data cell as well
so we'll just leave it at that i'll go
ahead and remove these examples that
gave the ids and we'll stick with scope
up above here so there we go i just
wanted to quickly discuss that that
there is another way to do it now that
we've completed adding the semantics to
our page and we're finished with our
table let's validate our code i'm going
to go to
validator.w3.org i'm going to drag the
page over just a little bit
click file
upload
and now when you click choose file make
sure you're grabbing the correct file
that you're in the correct folder i'm in
the 08 lesson here is the folder that i
want and i choose the index html and
click check
and document checking completed no
errors or warnings to show if you have
any errors it should show down here and
tell you which line they're on and give
you some information about correcting
those
so far the html we have created has
resulted in one-way communication but in
this lesson we're going to add a form to
our html page which will allow users to
send information back to us and that
makes our html interactive i've got
visual studio code open here on the left
with the starter code for the lesson and
on the right we're displaying that
starter code in the chrome browser and
i'm using the live server extension to
do that live server also immediately
updates the browser with any changes we
make in the code adding a form to a web
page allows us to gather information
from our users and more specifically it
allows our users to send us information
if they choose to this is exemplified
throughout the web with contact forms so
let's add one to our page notice i'm
near the top of the page around line 13
where the body element starts and if we
come down just a little ways we find our
nav element on line 17 now here i'm
going to highlight the last list item in
our unordered list that has planning and
vacation and i'm going to press shift
alt and the down arrow to just make a
copy of that below
here i'm going to add another anchor and
remember these are for links within the
same page i'm just going to change
vacation to contact in our new link
and i'll highlight the planning and
vacation and change that to contact me
so now we have made a link that should
show up here by our learning html and
planning a vacation so i'm going to
press ctrl s to save and there is our
new link and now we'll want to scroll in
visual studio code all the way to the
bottom and maybe i can just grab the bar
here and go a little faster because
after our last article that has the
places we do not want to visit on
vacation and we can see that in the
browser as well if i scroll that down
may take just a second to get there but
here we are places i want to avoid we
want to add our contact form underneath
this but above the footer as well so
underneath this last article but before
the main element closing tag so i'm on
line 170 right now i'm going to add
another hr a horizontal rule divider and
from there
we can start with our article element
i'm going to scroll up just a little to
get this closer to the center of the
page or a little higher and then we're
going to go ahead and add that id to the
article element and here we'll need this
to match what we put in the anchor link
above so it needs to say contact from
there let's go ahead and add our header
for the heading hierarchy and this
should be an h2 as it's a new article
area of our page so it matches the other
article areas and here i'll put contact
me for the title
now let's put a paragraph with a little
description underneath and so in the
paragraph i'll just put i'd really
like to hear from you
there we go and now we have
a title and we have a bit of a
description
and now we're ready to add our form to
the article so let's start out by typing
form and pressing tab notice an action
attribute is automatically added to the
form tag and what we want to put here is
where we're sending the information
usually this would be to our own server
but for this tutorial and just to
demonstrate what a form does we're going
to send it to a website that will
display
the information that we have sent with
the form so let's type https
colon slash
http bin
bin.org and then slash get now that last
part slash get refers to the method
we're going to use and that's the next
attribute that we need to add to our
form
so method equals get
likewise
method is often post as well there can
be other values and we'll see the
difference because we will try both of
those out before we're finished now the
contents of forms are mostly labels and
inputs and every input should have a
label so let's start with a label
element and notice it instantly has a
four attribute that four attribute value
should match the id value of the input
so here we're going to put first name
because that's what we expect
and then for the label this is the part
that will show on the page we also want
to put first name and then i'll put a
colon after that let's go ahead and
create an input and you can also type a
colon after the input and type t e x t
to get a text input and then press tab
and notice we automatically have the
type for the input filled out as text
and now we have a name attribute and an
id attribute and these you really want
to match so i'm going to put first name
and i forgot to put camel case here for
the label but i like to use that on
these so let's go first
name and by camel case that means the
second word has a capital so first name
with a capital n
and then for the name value we'll also
put first name that matches and let's do
the same with the id
now remember the id is the one that
absolutely needs to match the value of
the four in the label
this name attribute though
is how it is identified at the server
level so when we send this information
onto the server the information that is
in this input will be labeled with the
value that we put in the name attribute
so let's go ahead and save this much and
see what we get on our page we can
scroll down and look at our form it's
very basic right now but you can see the
title contact me
and the paragraph i'd really like to
hear from you and then we have our first
name label and our input where the user
can type information in this text input
but there are a few more attributes that
we can add so let's add one called a
placeholder now this lets us display
text but it's not the same as the value
which would actually be what the user
enters so this could just be an example
i'll type the name jane and save and now
we see jane in the text input but it
will not be sent with the form if we
click in that input and then start to
type
jane disappears and now we have a value
an actual value entered but as soon as i
delete the last letter jane will
reappear so placeholder is just
exactly that it is holding the place of
whatever value will be put in so
oftentimes there is example data in
there just to show the user what is
expected we can also add another
attribute called autocomplete
and autocomplete doesn't expect a yes or
no or true or false like others often do
with attributes as far as that goes this
is expecting an on or off so we're going
to turn the autocomplete on
and that means it will remember other
inputs that have been entered into this
field and suggest those so if we were to
submit the form and then
fill it out again later it might suggest
what we previously put in so that's a
preference thing if you want to have
autocomplete on or off
then we can put required and this will
require this field to have information
from the user before the form can be
submitted now notice i said autocomplete
didn't use true or false or yes or no
required does but we don't really have
to set it equal to
true like this we can just say required
because if we put required there it
equals true and then if we don't have
required there it's obviously false and
the last attribute we'll give this input
is auto focus now only one element in
the form or on the page can actually
have auto focus because it can't focus
on more than one at once
this will put the focus in that input
when the page loads so i'm going to save
and then if we reload the page we should
see the flashing cursor here there's
focus in there immediately when the page
loads so we can start typing instantly
when the page loads in that field now
i'm going to leave the autofocus here to
have it in the source code for you for
the lesson however with the contact us
page being at the bottom of the page it
may not be where you'd really want to
have auto focus if you were creating a
form okay and that completes our first
label and input combination for our form
now i'm going to highlight both of these
and press shift alt and the down arrow
so i can copy this down and i'm going to
change first name i'll press ctrl d to
highlight every instance of first name
which we have three and then arrow to
the front of it and then go three
letters in and just switch it to
last name so we can change all of those
at once again that's ctrl d
and it will let you select more than one
at a time for each time you press ctrl d
okay so now we have last name we need to
change here that didn't change this
instance of it because we had a space
between it so it was not the same as the
others
and we don't want a placeholder jane for
last name so we'll just put
do and then auto complete on i guess we
did it for the other one that's okay but
remember only one element or one input
can have auto focus on a page so we need
to remove that now let's go ahead and
save and you can see
our form has both inputs and labels it
doesn't look too great though does it
they're just all running along one line
and then wrapping to the next when it
runs out of room and with that problem
it may be better to wrap our label and
input in a block element that creates
that line break so let's use a paragraph
that once again better than using a div
a paragraph has just a little more
meaning than an empty div although
almost the same in this instance and you
will see some use divs here instead of
paragraphs so we've got a paragraph
there
now let's wrap the label and input for
the last name in another paragraph
and save and now let's look at our form
it has a little more space here this
looks a little bit better than before
okay let's keep adding to our form i'm
going to scroll up again we'll get the
last name towards the top of the page
i'll highlight the paragraph and
everything inside of it and shift alt
and the down arrow once again and now
we'll change last name to password so
ctrl d to select every instance of last
name again and i'm going to type
password so now we've got a four
attribute in the label and then the name
and the id
our password
so let's change our last name here
to a password value for label and type
text also needs to be changed to
password so this is a different type of
input than we used for first name and
last name
for placeholder
i'm going to put your secret
and autocomplete is not supported on a
password input so we can remove that but
we do want to go ahead and require a
password so now let's save
and we see our new input down here that
says password and has your secret for a
placeholder but now when i start to type
into this input
notice it has little dots instead of the
text and actually let me see if i can
just enlarge this a little bit so we can
see these better there we go so we see
little dots here inside of our input
and that is what a password field does
so it doesn't let the user see what is
being typed in okay let's scroll up
again and i will highlight the last
paragraph with the label and input shift
alt and the down arrow to copy
and now we're going to change this one
to something different let's say this is
a phone number so i'll once again select
well i just wanted the three but it's
going to change five now because we had
password in there so many times
so we can change the label to have a
capital p this is not a type phone
though that doesn't exist however type
tell does which is short for telephone
so we'll leave the four attribute on the
label the name attribute and the id
attribute values all to phone all lower
case for placeholder let's give an
example here and i'm going to put
555-555-5555
and if we wanted to leave it required we
could but we can add another attribute
here too
and i'm going to press enter just to
come down a line for this it is the
pattern attribute now the pattern
attribute
supports regular expression patterns and
that's almost like learning another
programming language if you're not
familiar i'll at least show you this one
that will give a pattern for a phone
number like we have shown in the
placeholder so
we're saying
zero to nine so this must only be
numerical digits and then we'll use a
curly brace and put the number three so
it should be three numerical digits then
we'll put the dash and now i'm going to
put the same pattern again because we
had
three more and another dash
and then finally it's going to be the
same pattern again because we want all
numbers and only numbers but this last
one should be four
and so that is a regular expression
pattern that would match what you see
here for the example now why else would
we put the type tell instead of type
text or type number well type number has
a little different display and it
actually provides arrows that would have
you click up and down we don't want that
but type tell also on mobile devices
should bring up a numeric keypad on the
screen instead of an alphanumeric
essentially with letters it should just
bring up what you would say dial for a
phone number and now that i'm thinking
about that the hyphen might not be
available on that numeric pad so let's
just make it simpler and go with all
numbers here
and remove those hyphens from our
pattern too so it could still match so
let's save this and now i'll go ahead
and copy this down but we'll look at a
example of a number input so we can
definitely see the difference right now
we see the phone input and it's input
type tell
and really we don't see anything any
different here besides that because
it still allows you to type a hyphen or
an underscore or anything else you want
in this input but we're just expecting
numbers and it will have to match this
pattern to allow the form to be
submitted so the pattern does enforce
what should be entered into that input
and now let's go ahead and highlight
phone i'll press ctrl d again and i'm
going to change this value
to decade
and we've changed the four attribute the
name attribute and the id attribute but
the label here that we want the user to
see is going to be
favorite
decade
now let's change the input type
to number let's go ahead and just remove
all of these attributes placeholder
pattern and required
and now let's add a minimum so we'll set
the min to 1950 this is where the range
will start
let's set the max
to 2020
and then there is an attribute called
step and that means
the interval in between essentially how
many years in this case will we be
switching between values and so we'll
just move decade by decade which is 10
years
and then the starting value so what we
want to display and we'll start with
1980.
so let's save this and now we see our
favorite decade input here at the bottom
and when i mouse over notice a couple of
arrows appear let me enlarge this one
more time
oh i enlarged the code instead here we
go let's enlarge the page one more time
scroll up and look at this form
i'll shrink the code there we go
and so when i mouse over
we see 1980 displayed but we get these
arrows so we can arrow down to 1970 all
the way to 1950 then i can't go any
further likewise i can go up to 2020 and
can't go any higher so our step interval
is working and our min and max are also
working and it's displaying numbers and
now we're going to look at a very
different kind of input so i'll just
start over and i won't copy everything
down
but i will start with a paragraph
element again inside the paragraph
element we will have a label
and it has a four value i'll put for
coffee because we'll ask what the user's
favorite coffee is
so we'll say favorite
coffee with a colon
and now underneath that instead of an
input element we're going to add what is
called a select element
now notice it still has a name and id so
we'll name or will assign the values
coffee to both of these as well
the id here still needs to match the
four for the label and will still have
the same name
for the input as it's received at the
server as well now notice we do have a
closing select element
and so with that closing select element
notice that's already different than the
input that does not have a closing tag
for the element
but inside of select we need to put
options so let's give our first option
element here and it has a value and
we'll set this to regular
coffee but now that's not what the user
sees the user is going to see what we
put between the opening option and
closing option tags so here i'm just
going to put
regular coffee
with caps instead of all lowercase
and now for the next
option let's put
iced coffee
and do the same thing as far as what the
user sees
there we go i need to scroll up just a
little more
and let's look at our next option
let's say this is a
latte
i hope i spelled that right
and let's give another option
let's call this
capuccino
cappuccino
c-a-p-p-u-c-c-i-n-o
there we go that's a little
one i don't think about every day well i
scrolled because i clicked just a little
too far to the right sorry about that
scrolling back down to our cappuccino
there it is i scrolled way up by mistake
get to the end of that line press enter
add one more option here
maybe two option let's put a cortado
and what else could we put oh yes what i
like to drink which is
an americano
so we've got several coffee drinks now
in our list
and maybe we should put other others
always good there because
there could be something we didn't think
of so let's just put an other selection
too
and save
and now if we look at our form over here
we can see the favorite coffee is here
with the select menu and we have to
click on the arrow and then all of our
options show and we can choose like i
would choose americano we could choose
other any one of these options and the
top one is what is showing but we could
decide to show a different one if we set
it as selected so in the options let's
say we want to display latte
by default
we would put selected here in the option
and if we save
now it displays latte by default so you
can choose which one displays instead of
just the top one now our code's looking
a little messy here as things started to
wrap lines so let me just expand visual
studio code for a little bit and you can
see how this looks much more organized
when the lines are not wrapping now
there's another element we can put in
here to help organize our selections so
let's do that and it's called an option
group and that is an opt
group
so once i tab over it gives us the
closing tag too i'm going to highlight
and control x to cut
and out of the coffees that we're going
to have because
this first group will be coffees it's
just the first two options so let's
close this here it will reformat as soon
as i save but we also need to put a
label attribute which is different than
a label element
so this label attribute on the option
group let's put
coffees with a capital c because you
will find out the user will see this
value
so now let's save this
and we're not going to look back at the
web page yet because we need to put
another opt group here for the other
coffees so now that we have that
i'll select the closing tag
and i'm going to put it after americano
other doesn't belong to a group and
that's okay too
but let's give another label here for
this group and this will be
espresso
drinks
and save now i'll resize visual studio
code
and we can look we still have our latte
selected as the default choice but now
if we expand this you can see coffees is
in bold we can't choose coffees i can't
choose espresso drinks but i can choose
regular coffee iced coffee
latte cappuccino cortado americano or
other
but our list is better organized because
we put in those option groups we can
make a couple of other changes too so
let's go back and just look at the code
again and these other changes are
actually attributes that will add back
to this parent select element so
one is multiple and that means we will
be able to select more than one choice
so we could select iced coffee and
americana's and then we want to put a
size value
and this size says how many from the
list will display
on the page at once so if we save that
you'll see what i mean by size now
notice
we have five values automatically
displaying on the page and notice latte
is already selected because we told it
to select latte but we could also hold
down the control button and click
regular coffee and now we have two
selected at once and i just noticed my
typo in the label where i only have one
e in coffee so i better fix that
put the other e in at the end of the
word and save okay i'm going to expand
visual studio code once again now this
looks nice on our page and it allows us
to select more than one coffee and
that's great but i want to show another
input that we could use for this same
type of data so right now starting on
line 199 i'm going to highlight
everything down to 214 now from the edit
menu i believe
there is yes toggle a blocked comment
and i do this with shift alt and the
letter a so
i'm going to select all this once again
this paragraph and press shift alt in
the letter a and when i do that notice
it comments everything out so i've kept
the code if we want to go back to that
but this is an html comment that we have
previously gone over in a past lesson
and it just comments the code out for
now so i'm going to paste in another way
that we could
use this same information and present it
to the user so here's the paste
and let me go ahead and return there so
we have the paragraph on a separate line
but notice we have a label it's for
coffee it says favorite coffee now we
don't have a select we have an input
type and it's a text type
and then it has a list attribute and it
says the list
is the coffee dash list then notice we
have a data list element and that id
matches the list attribute of the input
coffee dash list then i've got some
values here that are much like the
values that we saw in our select menu so
this is just another example now let's
save this and go back and look at our
page
and see what we've got it looks like a
text input now when i mouse over
notice the arrow
and if i click the arrow
there's our choices that we're getting
from the data list but what is nice
about this
if i just click in there they pop up and
i can start typing
and then it just narrows it down it
filters the list to what i started
typing so that's a different type of
input that can handle
very similar data presentation so okay
what i'm going to do now is highlight
that data list leave it in the code for
you but comment it out again
i pressed shift alt and the letter a to
do that
and i can reverse this comment by doing
the same thing so again line 199 all the
way down to 214
shift alt in the letter a and now it is
uncommented and so we've got our
original list back with the select and
i'll save that and you can see that now
on our page over here on the right okay
i'm going to expand visual studio code
again and now so far we have got fairly
good semantics for our form because we
are applying a label with the proper
four attribute for every type of input
that we have and that's good but when a
form gets large sometimes it's good to
organize it into different sections
sections that say what each part of the
form is about so underneath our form
element the opening tag here i'm going
to type a new tag
called field set
and now i'm going to go ahead and copy
that closing tag for the field set and
come all the way down to
just above our closing of the form as
well because this will be a section
where we've asked about the different
information such as the name and your
favorite coffee and so on and now
inside of this field set we can specify
one more element and this is called
legend it's a lot like a caption and
this is just saying what we're
requesting in this section of the form
and i'll put personal info here and then
we can save now let's go back and look
at our form again
and you can see it's surrounded this
section of the form because we're going
to add more to it yet so we just
sectioned off part of our form
essentially
it's got a square around it and personal
info the legend is part of that frame of
this section of the form and clearly
this does give some more semantic
meaning actually conveys meaning in our
structure as we define
part of the form and what it's about
okay let's continue to add to our form
now because there's some other types of
inputs we want to cover so let's scroll
all the way down
by our field set and now after the field
set we'll put in a break
and then we can add a new field set so
inside this field set we can add another
legend element and we're going to say
what is your
favorite food so this section of the
form is all about choosing a favorite
food
we'll start with a paragraph
inside this paragraph let's have an
input before the label this time
and this is going to be type radio radio
inputs are a little different
but let's give it a name attribute and
this will be for food
and now the id attribute is going to be
different than the name this time so
we're going to say tacos this is going
to actually be more like what the value
of the input is and we'll assign the
value attribute and here we'll say tacos
as well
so now that we've done that let's go
ahead and put the label underneath
and there we can have the four which it
should still match the id which is tacos
and then what do we want to show in the
label well of course tacos with a
capital t
okay now that we've done that we've
created one radio button so we need to
do a couple more so we have other food
choices i know tacos is the proper
choice but we should have a couple of
other choices here so i'm going to just
do shift alt and the down arrow twice
we've copied those down
we're going to leave the name attribute
food on all of these and that's because
you should only be able to select one of
these so when we select one the other
choice should
not be selected and that's what we
achieve by giving them all the same name
for the input but as far as tacos for
the id
and the value we can change that to
pizza
and we of course should change pizza
here oh and i should have changed the
four here to pizza as well so there
should be three now this last one let's
go ahead and select all three tacos
change it to other
and then here we'll say other as well
now i should note that if we had an id
of other we didn't with our option up
here that was separate
that had just the value of other as far
as the option and the name and the id
was coffee so we're good but you don't
want to double up you want to make sure
you have individual or unique ids for
each input in your form okay now that
we've added our new field set with the
choices for our favorite foods let's
take a look at that back on our page so
if we scroll up we've got what is your
favorite food and since they're all in
paragraphs which are their own block
elements they're each on their own line
inside of our field set so we can choose
tacos but then because they all have the
same name food if i choose pizza tacos
is no longer selected and it's only
pizza so you want to make sure
out of the radio buttons they all have
the same value for the name attribute
okay let's scroll down a little more and
let's add another field set and we'll
look at another type of input
inside this field set we'll have a
legend as well and here we're going to
say do you
have pets with a question mark
and now for our inputs
they're very similar to radio buttons
but not quite the same so i'll start out
with a paragraph
input
and the type is not text it is check box
and then once again there will be a name
and we'll set this equal to pets
and the id is going to be equal to dog
and then the value
is equal to dog so you can see the
pattern is much like when we were adding
radio buttons let me expand visual
studio code so this will be a little
easier
and now we'll go ahead and add a label
after that
and the label value will be for dog
and what we will display on the page
will be dog as well
so very similar i'll highlight this
we'll copy this down three times so now
we'll continue to have the value pets
for each one of these inputs
but the next pet will switch from dog
to
cat
and we'll put cat here on display as
well
and then maybe we want a fish
switch this to fish
and then finally
we could think about doing an other as
well but remember
we can't have an id that says other here
too we would be doubling up on that so
that could be a problem let's say
and select all three and say other
pet
and from there
we could say other because we just need
this to be different the id specifically
needs to be different than any other id
on the page or in the form now let's
save this and look at the page and there
will be a difference between the radio
buttons because when we ask do you have
pets and we have a check box maybe we
have a dog
and a fish and we can select more than
one at once a radio button won't let us
do that but a check box will so maybe we
have a dog and a frog so we choose other
you can select as many of these or as
few of these as you want to
okay let's expand visual studio code
again and we're down to our last input
type so
we've covered quite a few today already
let's add one more field set and inside
of here another legend as well and let's
put
send me
a note
so inside of this field set we're only
going to have one input but it's
definitely different than the others
this one is going to have a label
and in the four area we'll just put
message
and here we'll put
your message
and now underneath the label let's go
ahead and add a line break just to give
it a little space and then we'll add our
input which is a text area
this should have a name and an id and
you can also see it's automatically
given columns and rows
so for the name value we'll put message
likewise that should be the same for the
id since it needs to match r4
and for the columns and the rows let's
just leave it to the defaults here that
visual studio code gave us it's 30
columns that would be how wide it is and
rows 10 rows would be how deep it is so
now inside the text area here we could
put a value already this would be the
value or where the user would type but i
don't really want to do that i want to
leave it blank but we can add some other
attributes so for those attributes or
attribute i should say let's add a
placeholder
and inside of this placeholder we can go
ahead and put type your
message
here
and then we'll just leave this blank but
if you were to put it here it would be
like a text input setting the value
attribute but you don't really do that
for a text area you would just go ahead
and type
whatever you wanted to
right there and it would be the value in
the text area so let's save this and now
let's look back at our form again if we
scroll down we can see an area where
we're ready to type a message hey this
is
my message
there we go so
that you commonly see on a contact us
form you might have a area for the email
for a different message and so on but
this would be where you would typically
type a paragraph and i just mentioned
email that is another type of input
actually besides text and password so
you could say it would be a type email
it looks like a text input but it looks
for the at symbol to make sure it's
inside of the input as well so i did not
cover all inputs today but we covered
many of them and now we have a full form
but we're definitely missing something
yet we have no way to submit our form
after we fill it out so we need to add
submit button or buttons at the end
let's start out with one so after that
final field set we'll put in another
line break and then let's put in a
button element now a button element
should have a type we'll set that equal
to submit
note you might also see a form
that has a type
and here we should put submit there we
go so you might see an input with a type
submit and that can also create a button
the main difference here is that it only
takes a text value and that's what will
show up on the button
inside of a button element you could
actually put
more things than just a text value
inside of the button element so that
that is a big difference i like to use
the button elements overall because once
again it's a little more semantic here
we're saying it's a button and then we
can just set the type to a submit button
so here inside of the button i'm going
to type submit and that's what will show
up on the button so let's go ahead and
save
and now if i scroll down
we can see our submit button here that
is ready there's another type of button
though too and let's add it to our form
and let's go back and put a type
set this equal to
reset so if we wanted to reset our form
and clear out all of the values it's
fairly handy to have a reset button
every time i save it's going back up but
there we go submit and reset
and submit when you submit a page it
checks the validation immediately so
notice when i clicked
that submit button it said i needed to
fill this value out because it's
required and we didn't put a value in
there so i'll do that again
it instantly takes us up here and says
please fill out this field so we've got
more than one required let me put
dave in the first name
go back and click submit again
notice it takes me the last name and
says
please fill out this field so it's going
to do that for every required field
until they're all filled out so we could
put in anything in the password field
and i don't think we required anything
else let's take a look though maybe we
did no phone number is required so one
two three four five six seven eight nine
and let's leave it at that and it says
please match the requested format it
knows we haven't matched yet so i need
one more number
that should be good now if i submit
it's submitted now let's go ahead and
look at this what are we getting
from
http bin and boy that is bright but i'm
going to make this larger we see it's
it's labeled as args which means
arguments what were sent with the form
we didn't have everything filled out yet
but it did send our default value for
coffee and decade as well
we didn't have a message but it did at
least show that it was an empty message
and it shows what else we filled out
including the password notice that
doesn't mean it's encrypted it just
didn't show it to us as we entered it so
we have to consider that if we're
sending any sensitive information too
but overall
that is what we got so we could fill out
the rest of the form and see how all
that looks let's resize the browser
again
boy that is bright when we look at that
information but notice when we went back
the information is in all of these other
fields but it's not in the password
field we would have to re-enter that
every time and that's just part of being
with the password field so for favorite
coffee let's choose a couple here i'm
biased i want to choose americano
because that's my favorite
tacos is the correct answer here do i
have pets let's go with dog and other
because
well i've got two dogs really and then
we've got your message so i'll just put
hey this is
a
message
there we go let's submit again it's
going to be bright i know but okay nice
it fits on here the rest of this down
below is headers and just information
about how it was submitted with the
browser so that's server information but
this is what we're looking at notice now
coffee gave us both values we got the
latte and the americano
we got decade
first name oh and the server sorted this
in order of fields so food comes after
first name before last name there's
tacos
last name and a message and so on so we
got everything we expected to right
there let's add one more button to our
form
and this one will allow us to do
something that we haven't done before
and that is override what we are setting
in the actual original form action and
method so this will also be type submit
and you can have more than one submit
button perform and now this instead of
just having an action attribute will
have a form action attribute and here we
can provide a different address to send
the information to when we press this
button so i'm going to use a very
similar address it will be to the same
website https colon slash slash
let's go ahead and expand visual studio
code so we have some more room here
there we go http
bin dot org slash post so we're going to
use the post method instead of the get
method
and now
for the next attribute instead of just
method this is form
method and we'll set this equal to post
and so on the button itself instead of
submit i'm going to put post
and we can save and now this will allow
us to submit the same information
with a post instead of a submit now
notice all the information is cleared
out because we successfully submitted
before so i need to enter in
at least the required information again
and i believe that was the first four
fields
79 put a 1 there we should be good
and now let's go ahead and just press
post and see what we get
so we sent it post now to the same
website and you can see from the form
not just args as they were processing
with the get request however this is of
course just for this server it could be
processed differently on a different
server but we have our labels and we
have the information from the form
what's important to note
is that it says the origin where it was
sent from and different things here and
it says the url at the very bottom where
it was sent to and that is what we
specified
so now let's look at the same thing if
we are to send this information and i
need to put information back inside of
the password i guess it didn't clear out
because it was submitted before i
incorrectly said that it cleared out
because we made a change and saved the
html again so it reloaded here with live
server
but if we scroll to the bottom now and
just submit and this is remember is a
get request not a post request
now of course this htt bin shows this as
args up here instead of under the form
heading but once again we get all of our
information but what i want to show you
is when i scroll to the bottom
look at the url
now all of our information
is shown inside the url and that's what
happens with a get request so you never
want to send sensitive information with
a get request because if we looked up
here at this url we would see all of the
information inside of it matter of fact
i'll expand this it will be bright again
but there is all of our information in
the url and that's what happens when you
send a get request
okay headed back to our form resize so
now you have added a full
contact
form to your html page and this is maybe
a larger form than you would often add
but overall we've covered quite a few
inputs but remember to follow the mdn
links in the description because there
are even more inputs that i didn't have
time to cover okay we've reached the end
and it's time to validate our page let
me expand chrome here and we've got
validate by file upload we're going to
choose a file
and i'm going to be in my lesson 9 and
choose the index you choose the
index.html you've been working on
and then we'll click check just to see
if we have any errors or if everything
validates so we've got document checking
completed no errors or warnings to show
that's what we want if you do have
errors it will highlight those
welcome to your html project for
beginners you'll be using everything
you've learned about html5 to build a
website for the little taco shop let's
begin the html project let's get started
by looking at the little taco shop
website so we've got a basic website
here that we created with html
it has a nav menu at the top and an
image here in the header and then we've
got a description that says about lts
which is an abbreviation for little taco
shop and we can see that linked in the
nav so instantly we know that is an
anchor link and when we click it it
takes us directly to that part of the
page
has some information about lts and it
even has some emphasis on text here
where it says love of tacos we can see
some taco emojis and there is a link in
the directions to emojipedia where you
can get emojis and just paste them in
with your text emojis do work in html
there's a taco trivia section and you'll
have to go back in the lessons and
remember how
we showed something in the html and then
we're able to click the arrow and it
shows more information this is all done
with html not css
very minimal css is applied and
available in the style.css file inside
the css folder
if we scroll back up we can see there's
also a link to our menu and if we click
that it takes us to the part of the page
that has the menu and here the menu is a
table so you'll have to go back over
your knowledge of html tables and how to
create this table once again minimal css
is already available and it will apply
to the table as you create it of course
there's also a back to the top link and
we've got some copyright information
with an html entity for the copyright
sign at the bottom
we click back to the top we're back at
the top and we need to look at the store
hours page
and once we click that it navigates to
another html page so we've got
index.html and now the second page is
hours.html
it also has a navigation menu at the top
as you can see it's an unordered list
and you'll need to remember how to
create that
and now notice this is different now we
have a link to the home instead of the
hours page so it's not just the same
navigation it adapts to what page of
course and you'll have to create that
for each page we've got another image
and once again the image has a caption
and then we've got the hours this looks
like a list but you'll need to remember
what type of list creates a list that
looks like this where it says are open
seven days a week which is a description
such as a paragraph but then
this part starting with sunday and going
through the hours
is all a list we've got back to the top
again and we've got the same information
in the footer so let's click back to the
top and we have our menu now let's go to
the contact us page
and on the contact us page you can see
there's a link now back to the store
hours and also links to home and the
different parts of the home page now
that's something to consider too that
we're not just linking to another page
but we're linking to a section
of that home page
then there is the image little taco shop
tacos for the caption and we've got the
contact form and you can go back over
the forms tutorial to learn how to
create this form and you can submit this
form just like we did in the forms
tutorial we aren't creating the back end
that will process the form but you can
set it up to submit to the site we used
in the forms tutorial that will just
show the information submitted and then
there is an r location section and if
you remember the html element to use
for an address this is what you want to
put inside of that and look the link to
the phone number and if you're on a
mobile device this of course is a false
or fake number but this should actually
work as a phone number if you create the
correct link and we've got back to the
top again and that pretty much covers
the site but just to reference let's go
ahead and click the about lts which will
not only take us to the home page but to
the specific part of the page so you
also want to be able to link to that
specific part from another page not just
on the page itself such as when we
clicked about when we were on the home
page and it took us directly there so
you can also do that from other pages
now as we look at the starter files for
this project not only is there a
readme.md file that has the directions
and these directions are in a markdown
file that's what dot md is and this is
making it very easy to read on github
where you look at the resources and so
you can also just read them in here like
this but the other beginner files are
already here so you've already got a fav
icon that you would link to in the head
of each page
you've already got some css inside of
the css folder and you can link to this
style.css
in the head of every page as well you've
got all three images one for each page
here
and you've got some examples and these
examples are important because you'll
want to go back and reference that you
don't necessarily have to always go back
and pause the video you can just click
on the image and i have made full screen
captures
of the entire page so you don't have to
scroll you could zoom in a little if you
want to but you have these to reference
so here's the contact page when it shows
up there we go
and there's an hours capture as well so
you've got one for home one for hours
and one for contact and you can
reference these visually to help you
create these pages it looks like it just
takes a little bit to show up inside of
visual studio code of course you can
open these image files with some other
software if you want to as well or
directly in the browser and just keep
different tabs open to view each image
file if you want to that would also work
so there you go you've got to create
three html pages here in the root
of your tutorial folder and then
reference these other files and you've
got the examples to look at and you've
got the fave icon file already as well
so if we go back to the directions let
me see if i left anything out you've got
your files all named index hours and
contact we talked about that minimal css
available inside of the styles
file styles.css
all images are provided
and if you need taco emojis here's a
link to that as well and the fave icon
is included so that's everything good
luck with the challenge and then of
course after this you want to pause the
video and complete it to the best of
your ability and then all walk through
and create these pages with you for the
solution afterwards so don't do that now
pause the video and actually attempt it
on your own that's the best way to get
better at something try this out for
yourself before you allow me to walk you
through it
okay let's get started building our
project i'll close this readme.md and
i'll close any image file that we had
open before matter of fact i'll collapse
the examples and we're just going to
create the three html files that we need
first so we need
index.html
and then we also need
contact dot html
and if i remember right we need hours
dot html
okay with our three empty files created
let's go ahead and start on the first
one which is index.html we know every
document starts with doctype and if i
press tab it adds the html from there we
know we need the html i need lowercase
or i prefer lowercase and then we need
the attribute lang and that equals
english
is what i'll put of course you could put
something different there if you want to
we instantly get the closing html tag if
you don't of course add that as well
from there let's create the head section
so
here's the head element i've got the
closing head element and this will
contain several
meta elements the first one has the
character set attribute and we specify
utf-8
after that
i have another meta
and this is going to be name equals
author and of course this should be your
name i'll put my name here so
dave gray
after that
meta name equals description
and this is where we describe the page
so once again we have a content
attribute and i'm going to put
the official website for the and i need
to press alt z to wrap the code here
little oops i didn't get a space
little
taco shop
and i should really put a capital t
there as well because it's the official
name okay so we've got the little taco
shop
and of course that's what our title will
be for the page as well so we want the
little
need to spell this correctly the little
taco shop in the title as well
after the title let's add a link
and here we're going to say
rel which is related
it's an icon
and the href
and now let's put in that fave icon that
we have
and after that we'll say this is type
equals
image slash x dash
icon
and now let's add one more link tag
and how it's related to the page is it's
a style sheet
and now the href will point to that css
style sheet so we need
there it is css
and then we want style.css
and after that we can close our link tag
and we're finished with the head so i'm
going to press ctrl s to save now i
could copy this much and paste it into
the other two pages and just make a few
changes but i'm going to do just a few
more things before i do that so just
underneath the head we'll start our body
element
and then in the body element we'll start
with a header element
inside the header element we're going to
have an h1 and we'll say
welcome to
the little
still not typing that right there we go
the little
taco shop and that is our h1 heading for
the page remember every page should only
have one h1 header i'll scroll up now
for some more room
and now we'll start our nav element this
is where our navigation menu will be
we get that closing element inside the
nav element we're going to have an
unordered list
and then each list item will have a
different link so here we'll start out
with
let me put a line in between there we go
let's start out with our anchor tag and
the href is going to equal
hashtag about so this is going to link
to an about section on this page
so i'll say about right there and then
after that let's go ahead and put an
abbreviation element
inside of our link and here we can give
a title to this abbreviation and this
will be
the little i spelled it right that time
taco shop
and then we'll close that out and since
we're abbreviating we'll put lts so our
link says about lts
and now we can just copy this link item
down so highlight the full li and then i
press control alt and the down arrow
it should be the same for you on windows
it may be a little different on a mac or
linux
now the next link is much easier here so
we'll just say about it is hashtag menu
i want all lower case again
so no abbreviation for the menu
so it's just
about menu or i'll put our menu i think
that's what's actually on the page
and then from there we can copy this
down once again a little easier for the
next link
and let's copy it one more time there we
go three hour menus let's change this
second menu that's the hashtag menu to
our
hours.html so we're linking directly to
another page now
and then we can put
store hours
and then for this last one we'll remove
the hashtag menu and we'll put our
contact.html
and then we'll put contact us here
instead of our menu
now i'm going to scroll just a little
bit more and while we're still in the
header out of the nav
but in the header i'm going to add a
figure
and then inside this figure we'll add
our image so
here's our image element and we'll give
it a source equal to and then we want to
specify our image folder and then let's
pick our tacos and drink image
once we have that image we can add some
alt text for that that actually says
what it is so we'll put tacos and a
drink
remember alt text makes our images more
accessible and then we have a title
and we'll say
we love
tacos the title does not have to be the
same as the alt text and then let's
provide the width and i notice i saved
the width and the height in the image
name so the width is
400
and then the height
equals
267 and we can close out our image tag
but we're not quite finished with our
figure yet let's go ahead and add a fig
caption element and inside this will
give a description once again tacos and
a drink as our caption for the image
okay now we've completed the header so
let's once again scroll up for some more
room and then in between the header and
the main element let's put a horizontal
rule
and after that let's put a main element
where the body of our page will be and
it's right now let's leave a comment
saying
our content will go here and then after
that we'll have another hr
and then we'll have a footer element and
now we need to put something in the
footer as well if you remember from the
example each footer had a paragraph that
said copyright
and now we need to use an html entity
for the copyright symbol and that is
ampersand copy with a semicolon and then
we'll just say the
little
taco shop
and now we can save this and now we're
really ready to copy all of this code
and put it into the other pages as well
and we'll just need to make a few
changes and then when we add actual
content to each of the pages that's
where it will really differ so i'm going
to press ctrl a to highlight everything
and then control c to copy everything
go to the contact page and press control
v to paste that in
control s to save
go to the hours page and do the same
control v to paste it all in
and control s to save ok while we're on
the hours page let's make the changes
here first i need to press alt z again
in each one of these files to get the
code to wrap in each one so now we can
make our changes everything is the same
as far as the author and the content but
when we get to description we'll have a
different description this will be store
hours for the little taco shop
and now that we've changed our
description we can also change our title
instead of the little taco shop here
let's put lts
hours since it's not the home page we'll
just go ahead and abbreviate
as we can assume the owner employees and
even the townspeople in the little town
for the little taco shop refer to the
little taco shop as lts now let's scroll
down into the body where we have our
header and a little bit needs to change
here too so it's not welcome to the
little taco shop here we'll put the
little taco shop
and then
hours after that and now our nav is
going to change somewhat too so it's not
just a link to about lts we need to go
to another page and if you remember we
can just go to the slash to go to the
home page so here we need slash about to
go to the about section of the little
taco shop on the home page so we'll do
the same for the menu and now
where we have hours we can just
eliminate this because we're going to
put in a home link instead so i'm going
to press control x to cut it out
then just backspace out that extra line
here scroll to the very top
and paste in the one that i just cut out
and now we're going to link to just that
slash that i was talking about and that
will link to the home page so let's
change the store hours
to home
and i'll save that much now let's scroll
down a little bit further and we need to
change out our image as well so
now we're not going to use the tacos in
a drink image we wouldn't want that on
more than one page so now i want image
slash and we'll choose tacos tray now
notice it's also 400 by 267 so we don't
need to change that but let's change
what it says here for the alt text and
we'll say a
tray of
tasty
tacos and then we can add a tray of
tasty tacos for the fig caption as well
i should have just highlighted that copy
and paste again ctrl c
over the fig caption and control v
and we could leave we love tacos for the
title here as well
but let's put we
love trays of tacos that's some nice
title text as well and remember the
title shows when you put your mouse over
the image and if we scroll down we don't
really need to change anything because
the footer stays the same between all
the pages so we're finished with the
immediate changes to the hours html now
let's go make those same types of
changes to the contact.html i need to
scroll back up to the top first and
press alt z to get the code to wrap now
we need to change the description again
so let's change this to
contact
information for the little taco shop
and let's change the title for the page
as well
and here we'll put
contact us
and then let's put a dash and put lts
just because we want the lts in the
title for everything that's not the home
page
and we leave everything else the same so
now we can scroll up and this is the
contact us page so let's highlight this
h1
and change this part to contact us
and now for the about once again we
could actually go over to the hours
and now let's copy this nav and we'll
just have to change a little bit less
that way so copy the nav
and now we'll highlight the nav that we
have in here
and paste in the new one from the hours
page so now we have the same home link
we have the same about link we have the
same
menu link and we only need to change
contact to hours so this will link to
hours and then we just change this
contact us
to store hours
and let's save that much okay scrolling
down to the figure we need to change out
our image again
this one's just a little different so
now we've already had tacos and a drink
and the tacos trade this is tacos close
up notice the size is a little different
400 by 260. so
we've got 400 here but we need to change
this to 260 instead of 267.
okay now our alt of course will be a
little different as well this will be
little
taco shop
tacos
and now for the title let's put tacos
ready to eat
and then we can put little taco shop
tacos here too so i'll once again
highlight that alt text
and put the same text in here for the
caption that we're showing on the page
and if we scroll down we can see our
footer remains the same here too so
let's save the page and we're ready to
begin working on content for each of the
pages okay i'm going back to the
index.html
and i'm going to click go live or i
could right click
and choose
open with live server because we're
using the live server extension to view
our web page and we can go ahead and
start looking at our page it doesn't
have a lot on it but it has enough to
get started here we've got our header
section and we've got the menu with the
different links so now i'm going back to
the code i'm going to resize visual
studio code and press control b to hide
the file tree so i have more room to see
the code and we're ready to add content
to the page inside of the main element
i'll delete that and we'll start with
an article element i'm going to give
this an id equal to about so our about
anchor tag works our link works now i'll
put an h2
and inside the h2 i'm going to put about
and then we need that
abbreviation with the title value again
of
the little
taco shop
and now we'll put
l
ts there we go
and that completes the header so now
let's put some content we'll have a
paragraph here
and i'm going to take that same
abbreviation and start the paragraph
with that so
lts
was founded in and now remember we can
use a time element to give some meaning
to the dates and times we put on our
page so i'm going to put a time element
here with a date time
equal to 2022
so the little taco shop is a fairly new
location
get a period at the end of that sentence
and we can put our shop was built
on
or was built from there we go
a
love
of tacos and now we'll put a period
there we'll say we hope
our shop
adds a unique
and interesting
place to our little town
now let's add just a little more flavor
to this paragraph so we can put a strong
element
and then we'll put love of tacos inside
that so it has some emphasis
and now we also want to add some taco
emojis right after that so let's go to a
new window and i'm going to type in
emojipedia.org and there you can search
for emojis i'm searching for taco
once i find taco i'm going to click that
and it allows me to copy that emoji so
after i say a love of tacos i'll put a
space and control v
control v control v just pasted in three
tacos so i'm going to close out
emojipedia we no longer need that but
let's save this and see what we get on
our page
so now if we look at this we've got
about lts and there's the abbreviation
and when we mouse over we get little
taco shop
and now we've got our paragraph for the
about information now i'm going to
scroll up just a little more but right
after the paragraph i'm going to use
another semantic element called aside if
you remember that one and for the aside
i'm going to put an h3 header so we're
following that header hierarchy
put taco
trivia so for taco trivia we're going to
have a question that only shows the
answer when you click on it and for that
we need to start out with a
details element
and then inside the details element
we're going to use a summary element so
inside the summer is where we ask the
question and we can say
when did tacos
first appear in the united states
and now the nice thing is this question
will show but you'll have to click an
arrow to see the answer that is
contained within and that's within just
the rest of the details here and it's a
paragraph now i'm going to copy and
paste this paragraph in and put it right
here now notice i added another time
element here with 1905 and we can save
that much and we can see our taco trivia
down here at the bottom and when we
click we see the rest of this but
there's just a little more i would like
to add and it actually has one element
in there that was not covered in prior
lessons but remember there is a wealth
of information and many different
elements that still remain uncovered i
guess they're not used as often but you
can look them up on the mozilla
developer network so i'm going to put in
a citation and there is an element in
there called site so right after this
i'll paste in the citation and here you
can see i put the source let me expand
visual studio code that's getting a
little cramped you can see i put the
source
and then i put a site element c-i-t-e
and inside that site element i put the
link to the source
so that is right there and that's
smithsonian magazine so now if i save
i'll resize once again to come back and
look at our taco trivia and when i show
the information you can see the citation
is put in italics by default with that
site element okay let's resize visual
studio code again to get a little more
room and scroll up as well after that
aside we have really completed our first
article so let's put a horizontal rule
in here which also indicates a topic
change at least somewhat
in the main area and put another article
now this article i didn't add the id but
it needs the id because the id equals
menu and this is where we will put the
little taco shop menu we'll start with
an h2 again to follow the header
hierarchy for our page and we'll put
our menu for that and then we'll start
our table element
inside the table element the first thing
we're going to add just immediately if i
could start is a caption there we go and
we'll just put our tacos for the caption
after that we need a t head
inside the t head will be a table row
and the table row is going to have our
columns and these are our heading
columns so the first one
is tacos
after tacos we're going to have
a second th
and this th is going to have well let me
go ahead and type th again there we go
this th is going to have a scope and
let's set this scope equal to column
because it's for the column
and then we need our abbreviation
element once again so let's type abbr
and then we'll put the title equal to
quantity
and now we can put in the abbreviation
for quantity that we want to use which
is commonly qty
and then we'll add another th
and it will also have a scope
let's set this equal to column as well
and this will be
the price column okay going to scroll up
as you might have realized when we
learned about tables tables take up a
lot more space as you create them in
your code
so we've completed the head and we need
more room for
the body of the table let's add a new
row
and inside this row we're going to add
another heading but this will have a
different scope so now that we're back
there we'll go scope
equals row
and now that we're ready to put in the
value let's call this crunchy but i did
forget an attribute this also needs a
row span so this will have a row span
equal to three
okay after we've created the scope and
the row span with crunchy we can't
forget the values of the other columns
so now we need one for the quantity and
for the next one which was price we need
a dollar fifty so there's our first row
and now we can create more rows but what
i really want to do is just take these
last three
and do shift alt and the down arrow and
then add an opening tr here i wanted to
add a closing tr as well but we don't
need that because
this crunchy is taking up three rows so
we don't want to add that row down here
we just need the other two rows so let's
turn this one into two dollar or two
quantity of two
and two dollars and fifty cents
now i'll just highlight this row
and take it down one more time and we'll
have a quantity of three
and we'll put
three dollars
and 25 cents so now we've got the feel
of this where we've got the first one
with the title and it's taking up three
rows and then we've got the quantity and
the price so what i want to do for the
next one is to just highlight
all of these
and press shift alt and the down arrow
and once again just make changes so this
is going to be soft instead of crunchy
and now we still got a quantity of 1 but
is the price the same and no it's not
soft tacos are a little more expensive
so two dollars
and then for two soft tacos it's 350 and
for three soft tacos it is
450. now let's scroll up some more we
finished with the body but we need to
add the footer to the table and that's
the t foot element and now inside the t
foot we're going to have a table row
and then we'll have a data cell table
data and it's going to have a call span
attribute so it's going to span all of
the columns so that's three
and then inside of the table data we'll
put chips
and then and amp
is for the ampersand that is another
html entity
and then we put salsa
two dollars and now we've completed our
table but underneath the table in this
last article let's go ahead and put
a line break and after the break let's
put a paragraph and let's go ahead and
add our back to top link so now we'll
have an a with an href
we'll set this equal to the hashtag
which should just reload the page take
us back to the top
and we can save so now let's resize
visual studio code and see if we have
all of our content yes we've got the
crunchy that took three rows and the
soft that took three rows there's the
table footer
everything looks like we planned it
and our back to top link is here it
takes us back to the top as well
our taco trivia
everything is good about the home page
so now let's work on the store hours
page it is a fairly short page and there
you can see it displayed to the right
and we'll pull up the code here on the
left okay let's scroll down and we've
just got a little bit of content to add
in the main area here of the body inside
the main element
so we'll start out with a paragraph
and inside this paragraph we'll just say
we are open
seven days
a week with an exclamation mark after
that we need to add a data list so it
starts out with a dl element
inside the dl element we'll have a dt
and this is where we'll put our sunday
dash thursday so sunday through thursday
and then underneath that we'll have a dd
element and that's where we'll put our
11 am
dash 9 pm
so now we can just copy this down
because there's only one more that was
like it and we can just change the days
out so now
this will be
friday
saturday and then the hours are
different as well it's 11 am to
11 pm
and we can save that
now we also need to add a back to the
top link as well so here's our paragraph
and then we can say
a with href once again equal to the
hashtag
and back to top
and save once again
and now we can see all of this here on
the right our back to top really isn't
needed because it's so short but we're
just consistent between each page and
that's fine so now let's go over to the
menu page or not the menu i'm sorry we
want to go to the contact us page that's
where we are the menu is on the home
page i don't know about you but i'm
starting to get hungry when i look at
those so let's finish up this project so
we can go get some tacos i'm going to
scroll up and once again we're going to
change out
the
comment inside of the main element and
put in our content we'll start with an
h2 following the header hierarchy
remember we already have contact us up
here in the header i believe if we
scroll up there there's the h1 so we
want an h2 here
and this h2 is going to say our
contact
form
okay now we need to go ahead and create
this form so we'll start with the form
element and let's go ahead and give it
an action well
there we go form
tab over and it gives us the action
there we go and we'll send this to that
same website we used in the forms
tutorial that's http
bin dot org slash get so we're going to
use a get method when we submit it and
we'll at least be able to see the
information on that website so as i said
we use the get method so let's go ahead
and apply that attribute as well method
equals get
after that i'm going to put some space
here in the form and we need a field set
element
now we can put our form inside the field
set element and then we'll have a legend
element and here we'll say send us a
message
and then we can start in with the
description of our form
so we have a paragraph and then we have
a label
and then it has a four and this will be
name and so then we need to put name
inside the label as we label the input
and now we need that input so here's the
input
let's give it a
type
there we go text there it is text now we
put in the name which is name and the id
which is going to be
name as well
now i want a placeholder element here
also
and this placeholder is going to say
your name giving the user a clue as to
what to put in
and let's put in required as we want the
username to be required before they can
submit the form scroll just a little
more for some more room i'm going to
highlight this paragraph now and once
again shift alt and the down arrow and
now i've already got my label and input
and i just need to change some of these
things so this will be email
and we'll change name here to
email as well
and now this will be an email input and
then for the name
and id i'm going to press ctrl d
for each of those remaining name words
and then i can change them all at once
to email okay i'm going to save this
much and we see the beginning of our
form over here but we still need the
area to put in the message
so i think i want to scroll some more
for that and then return once again one
more paragraph inside this paragraph
let's have a label
and now the four here is going to be
message
and now inside the label we'll also put
well we'll put your message here that's
fine
and then we need a text area which is a
little bit different than a text input
this is going to have the name of
message and it should have the id of
message as well
columns 30 and rows 10 that's fine that
is the default and then placeholder also
so let's put a placeholder
let's set that equal to type your
message here
and then the actual message of course
goes inside the text area so we'll save
that and now we should see a place they
can put their message oh but we can see
it looks a little different this doesn't
look quite right let's put a break after
that label
and then it should put the label up on
top of that message box now let's scroll
a little bit more and after the field
set but important enough before the form
has ended we need to put a button and
then inside of this button let's give it
an attribute which is type equals
submit and then let's go ahead and put
send for the button text i'm going to
copy this down
control alt and the down arrow and now
this type will be reset so we have a
second button
and we can put reset here as well so
now let's save and we should see our
buttons that will send or reset the form
and as i look at everything i've noticed
something we put our form inside the
main element but i wanted to wrap that
inside of a semantic tag as well not
just the main element
but i wanted to put it inside of a
section element so let's go ahead and
put a section element there
and we will
copy that or cut that actually with
control x and scroll all the way down to
where the form ends and put the closing
section there now let's save that
it doesn't make the page look any
different but it holds up the html
semantics better and the main reason we
need it is because the form is not the
only content of the page so we have
another section here and this section
has an h2 of its own and here we can put
our location which goes nicely with a
contact us page as well so now we've got
the h2 there and we need an address
element because now we can put our
location inside of this address element
so it's 555
taco
temptation
lane and then it's at sweet tea
line break and then kansas city
missouri and then 555-555-5555
completely fictitious zip code
after that we'll put in a line break and
another line break
and then let's put in a phone number
which is also fictitious but we want an
actual link that will work
to make your phone or whatever mobile
device dial the phone number and we can
do that with the tell abbreviation
and then we need
a plus
and then
five five five five five five five five
five five there we go
and then we can put the link so it's
555-555-5555
and now we've completed the address
section so if we save that and scroll up
a little bit
there is the location information and
with that i believe we have completed
our website in the three pages so
i hope this tutorial has helped and more
than that i hope you were able to
complete much of it on your own before
watching the tutorial let's expand
chrome and look at our overall site so
if we go to the home page here it is
here's everything we added
here's the back to the top link that
works too we can go to the menu that's
great we should be able to go to the
about lts yep that works good too
mouse over an image and we get our title
text all of that's as expected store
hours
everything looks like it should here as
well and then the contact us page
everything's looking good here let's go
ahead and try the contactless
information so then we say dave
at dave
dot
dave whatever and then
dave in the message that's fine
send and yes it goes to the http
http bin.org
and we see the information from the form
and that's a great site to test out
forms on so everything is looking as it
should i'm ready to go get some tacos
congratulations on completing your html
project